hey guys welcome to an ALT shift X live
stream to talk about House of the Dragon
episode
5. oh my god
there was a lot going on this episode
this is kind of like a like like a like
a mid-season finale or something
um this is a this is a big moment
setting up so many of the conflicts for
the rest of the season for the rest of
the story so many of these relationships
these events this episode sets up so
many of the relationships going forward
um
I everyone has beef with everyone
everyone has secrets from everyone else
everyone has
so much potential so it's uh it's wild
we're gonna talk all about the episode
We're Not Gonna spoil future episodes
we're gonna answer your questions and
we're gonna have a good time so thank
you for joining in to this live stream
let's talk about it I feel like Kristen
Cole was kind of the star of this
episode for me he had so many feelings
and and so few brain cells
um he was so tortured by having had sex
with rhaenyra and broken his vows that
he was willing to confess his sin to
Alison he was ready to kill himself
before the Heart Tree
which I thought itself was an
interesting choice I I thought it was
interesting that Kristen would go to a
Heart Tree rather than to the sept of
the faith of the seven say uh but then
you know Alison came and and saved him
um and and Alison sort of had Christian
by the Bulls because she knew his secret
because he confessed to her and that was
how Alison found out uh that rhaenyra
had lied to her Alison had
had believed her friend when Rainier
said hey I did not have sex with Damon
she she swore on her mother's memory
that Damon didn't touch her and now
Alison found out that she did have sex
that night albeit with Kristen not Damon
but then Alison is so betrayed and so
angry that Rainier is lie she sees it is
such a betrayal
and you know that's partly why Allison's
father Otto was was kicked out of King's
Landing is because Alison believed
Rainier and told King viserys hey I
believe rhaenyra not Otto and so that's
part of why Otto her father got sent
away and now she's realized that's a lie
so she makes this wonderfully dramatic
entrance like this whole wedding was
just dramatic entrance after dramatic
entrance like you had Jason Lannister
walk in you had the hightowers come in
you had Daemon walking despite the fact
that he had just been exiled he walks
right the [ __ ] in and then the the Royce
guy accuses Damon of murder and then
like it's just a whole procession of
people who have beef and want everyone
to know how much beef they have but this
color green it's all about Alison's
house Hightower identity and objecting
to Rainier as lies you know placing
herself in
in opposition to rhaenyra the Targaryen
and then of course you've got the
valerions ascendant because the
valerion's intermarrying with the Royal
house and we had all of this dick
measuring about like so you know
rhaenyra and Lena's children are they
going to be valerions or targaryens
because if their children are on the
throne like Carlos would love the king
of Westeros to have his valerion name
but viserys is like no no it's going to
be a Targaryen thing I I feel like male
pride is a big theme this episode like
we had viserys as his body is just
falling apart he the man is
disintegrating melting into a puddle
before us and his concern is like how
will I be remembered you know oh I kind
of wish there were a few Wars in my
reign so I could have proved myself you
know I wish I was tested so I'd be
remembered better
there's a lot of like male dick
measuring Behind These alliances and
things so oh my God there is uh there's
a lot going on
um thank you for the Super Chat from
Marcella deliveria uh who says uh House
of the Dragon character alignments yeah
maybe the YouTuber alt Rift X might talk
about House of the Dragon soon thanks
for the Super Chat from Alexander who
says Alison and Kristen together as the
head empty Club this week yeah I feel
like Kristen was not operating with with
the with the full picnic basket this
week Alison was not dumb I mean Alison I
mean Otto accused Alison of saying like
hey you're thinking with your heart
instead of with your brain
um because Alison sort of wants to
believe that she and Rainier can get
along
um But Otto is saying that no like the
fact of it is a lot of people will not
support Rainier as Queen like we saw
that at the hunt when like the land
investors and other Lords and the
hightowers are all assuming that
Alison's baby son aegon is going to be
the heir to the throne not rhaenyra and
Alison you know partly because she's so
lonely and and rainyro is like her only
friend or the closest thing that she has
to a friend Alison wants to believe that
peace with rhaenyra is possible But Otto
is saying due to the realities of
politics there's gonna be conflict
viserys is is keeps on saying rhaenyra
is going to be Queen and now of course
we've got the valerions
the valerions are married to rhaenyra so
callus you know as one of the most
powerful and richest Lords in the realm
he's going to be supporting uh rhaenyra
and Lenor while people like the
hightowers who were probably like you
know one of the other most powerful
houses in the realm of supporting
elephant and her baby let's have a look
at the family tree just so we all know
where we are in this this situation
um so Allison and viserys have two kids
now and aegon this is the baby that they
uh are thinking maybe the heir to the
throne though officially vasera says
that his daughter rhaenyra is going to
be the heir to the throne and rhaenyra
has now married Lenor valarion uh who is
the sibling of Lena valarion Elena has
grown up we saw like an older uh Elena
valerion uh at high tide which is the
house of
um the seat of house for Larry on this
is the castle that call us for larion
built with all of the money that he made
from his nine voyages across the world
um I wish we saw a bit more of Lena
because she's like an interesting and
important character
um but we didn't really learn much about
her this episode apart from the fact
that she has grown up an awful lot she's
grown a lot since the last time we saw
her she was you know Elena was the tiny
child who uh proposed marriage to
viserys but he rejected her so that
valerians were mad
but now that the valerians have married
rhaenyra through laneor that's
potentially really important Alliance I
enjoyed seeing uh rhaenys this episode I
really enjoyed rhaenis's entrance
um I thought rhaenys had a lot of
personality in the brief moment that she
was here
um so yeah it's good to see more of
these secondary characters thanks for
the Super Chat from cheese breads who
says first we had Littlefinger now we
have Bigfoot we sure do Laris strong the
club foot uh he was fantastic this
episode I really enjoyed larys the club
foot he's kind of like Littlefinger he's
kind of like Varys he's like this sort
of smart scheming Outsider manipulator
and you know Laris the clubfoot maybe
played the most important role in this
entire episode because it was Laris the
clubfoot who came up to Alison and said
huh I heard that rhaenyra is a little
bit sick because rhaenyra got a special
T from Grand maester Melos because
remember
um Melos gave Alison to the uh the moon
T the the the plan t uh last episode to
end any pregnancy that Rainier may have
from having sex with Damon slash Kristen
and Lara strong has somehow become aware
of this I wonder how he found that out
but Laris uses this information to
basically tell Alison that hey your
friend lied to you like Laris basically
manipulates Alison against rhaenyra by
telling her that Rainier drank Moon tea
um so you know what is Laris the
clubfoot's angle here is he just
creating chaos for the sake of chaos is
he like Littlefinger does he use chaos
to gain uh Power because like you know
the clubfoot says like hey like you know
perhaps you're in need of an ally the
clubfoot says which is like hey I'll be
your friend in this conflict that I have
created between you and Rainier so uh
yeah I I really enjoyed the club for
this episode I also really enjoyed his
brother break bones
um because uh
Harwin strong the uh the older brother
of Laris the clubfoot I love how uh his
father Lionel just sort of gave
um break bones a nod he just sort of
nodded to his son breakbones and he's
like yeah I need you to go in there and
so breakpoint is like yep I've got this
and he just walks into the scrum into
the melee uh and just pulls out the
princess and like carries Rainier out of
the violence over his shoulder because
like he's this big strong guy um he's
said to be the strongest Knight in the
realm and I will you know he doesn't
look like the strongest guy in the realm
like he's no griggle Clegane from
looking at him
but I think they communicated really
well in this moment that like he's the
guy who if you need something done
physically you send brake bones in to do
the work and uh by God he did it
um
Evan Stanger in the live chat says Laris
gave a master class on subtle
manipulation yeah I thought the clubfoot
was wonderful here and he seems to be
setting himself up as an ally of Alison
thanks for the Super Chat from Alexander
who says uh not sure I'm a fan of Ria's
murder scene failed almost too cruel not
sure I can ever support Daemon yeah I
mean I feel like I've been saying this
all along but like Daemon is not a great
guy I mean in episode one we saw Daemon
like going to town on the common people
for fun well I mean for several reasons
but like we saw Daemon with his gold
cloaks just leading this violent assault
on just random common people I mean
supposedly he was going after criminals
maybe these people in episode 1 were
like known criminals who he was bringing
to justice but like there were a lot of
people getting cut into pieces and he
was personally enjoying it like I feel
like enjoying mutilating people is kind
of the definition of evil and he's been
that all along he's also been like
politically disruptive he's been cruel
like insulting Otto over his dead wife
you know cheating in the tournaments
like Daemon Daemon is not great I mean
he is very charismatic and he's very fun
to watch and he's a very fun character
um not a great guy and I feel like yeah
him killing Ria Royce here his wife uh
is part of that but I mean there is some
ambiguity here right because you know
Daemon approaches her and then she
reaches for her bow
and then Daemon sort of steps forward
and grabs the horse and then the horse
rears up and then she falls down and so
like Daemon did not exactly cause her to
be injured initially uh he starts to
walk away and then she like insults him
so he picks up a rock to kill her
um so it's like well what were daemon's
intentions from the start you know like
did Daemon come to the veil to murder
his wife or did he just come to mess
with her and insult her some more or you
know I mean he came to the veil because
his brother King viserys told him to go
back to the veil he was commanded by the
king to go to the veil so I suppose
that's why he did it
so he just like comes you know honey I'm
home uh isn't this how you come home to
your wife you just uh stand hooded under
a giant cloak just stand stand in the
driveway hey honey I'm home
um and yeah he kills the weather Rock so
I I think I think Damon's not not great
if we're being honest um and while we're
here uh house Royce is of course uh the
family of bronze on Royce so they're one
of the oldest and most powerful houses
in the veil they are sworn to house
Aaron you know like lady Lisa Aaron
um one of the the strongest allies is
house Royce they go all the way back to
the first men uh who fought against The
andal Invasion and they famously wear
this very fancy ancient bronze runic
armor of the first men that supposedly
protects them from all harm uh though
nonetheless many Royce Lords have died
in this magical armor
um waymar Royce from game Game of
Thrones season 1 episode 1 got killed by
a white walker he was a royce there was
also a rice in renley's Rainbow guard
supporting Renly Baratheon so the royces
have uh have a role all throughout the
story and it's nice to see them make an
appearance as uh Damon's wife though we
did not know her long sadly I quite
liked
the dynamic between Daemon and Reya like
you know we we sort of get the sense
that you know maybe part of why Daemon
dislikes Reya is because Raya does not
take any of daemon's [ __ ] you know
um like you you look at the dynamic
between like Daemon and viserys like
viserys is always rejecting Daemon and
exiling him but he's always accepting
him back you know like at the feast you
know viserys just allows Daemon to
return right back in onto the high table
like he just walks right up and there's
like no confrontation there's no words
there's no apology there's no nothing
viserys just allows Daemon to return
despite the fact that he had exiled him
you know viserys just he he lets Damon
walk all over him whereas Raya Royce
just took none of daemon's [ __ ] and I
think that Daemon just couldn't handle
that
um and you know she seems like a pretty
free-spirited person who you know goes
off and does her own thing like she told
her cousin nah like I'm gonna go hunt on
my own I'm gonna do this myself you know
like Daemon I think wants he wants
people to want him he wants people to
you know need him and and Reya doesn't
so maybe that's part of why their
relationship didn't happen uh
Elena in the live chat says Raya Royce
was hot as [ __ ] I don't care what Daemon
was complaining about yeah yeah I don't
know what Damon was complaining about
yeah she she seems super cool and I
think maybe Daemon couldn't handle that
his wife Ria was clearly more cool than
he was thanks for the Super Chat from
Neil and from Ryan Ryan says are we
calling this the green wedding because
of Alison's dress yeah I mean there's a
long tradition of course of um of
weddings in Game of Thrones going badly
there's the Red Wedding with Rob and the
phrase and there's the purple wedding
where Joffrey got poisoned spoilers for
the original Game of Thrones series by
the way we're not going to spoil the
future of House of the Dragon but we
will spoil what happened in the original
Game of Thrones show thanks for the
Super Chat from Morgan who says can you
please elaborate on house runestone yeah
so so Rune stone is the castle of house
Royce I feel like we already discussed
house Royce a bit
um there's a girl called Miranda Royce
uh daughter of Nestor Royce who works at
like the gates of the moon in the veil
and in the fourth Game of Thrones book
and Beyond there's a whole sort of plot
line happening with Littlefinger and
Sansa and
um the royces and the veil because the
royces oppose Littlefinger basically
taking over the veil so you know that's
a that's a whole thing maybe we'll do
like a video about house Royce sometime
that might be fun uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Red salt oh actually one
other detail that I really enjoyed about
Rhea and Damon is that Reya said oh have
you come here to consummate uh
consummate our marriage and she says
something about like Daemon couldn't
finish
I I thought it was interesting
um and Daemon like the whole time was
like not saying a word I think it's
really interesting that sometimes Daemon
is like really snarky and sometimes
Daemon is really insulting and saying
all this stuff
um but sometimes Daemon is just dead
silent and I think when he's dead silent
that is when he's more dangerous
um but he's very moody you know
sometimes he's chatty sometimes he's
insulting whereas sometimes he's just
dead silent and it's very scary
um yeah and it's interesting that Reya
says that you know King viserys cast
Daemon aside in favor of rhaenyra so
like Reya is very aware of how Daemon is
angry and insecure about viserys
rejecting him and making Rainier instead
um so reyer is like very aware of like
how to piss off tamon
um and she suggests that Daemon might
try and kill rhaeniro which is
interesting but yeah she said something
about like Daemon couldn't finish
um so maybe Daemon has a long history of
like reproductive failure I can't get it
up or whatever uh and Reya knows it and
maybe that's part of why Daemon is is so
pissy with her thanks for the Super Chat
from Red salt who says the music in this
episode was brilliant the plot and
dialogue rivaled episodes like the
Reigns of Castamere do you think they
will be able to hold up this standard
yeah I I continue to be impressed I'm
I'm really enjoying this show
um I thought that the dialogue this
episode sounded a lot more sort of
formal and you know sort of like
Shakespearean like fancy old-timey
language in this episode compared to the
previous episode I'd suppose it's like a
different writer it did sound a bit
different a bit more formal to me this
episode but um yeah I enjoyed it
um I also really enjoyed the music when
when Daemon sort of uh made his entrance
like it was this very sort of ominous oh
[ __ ] it's this guy this guy turned up to
the party
um thanks for the donation from xfelios
who says elephant stumbling into the
truth because she's unwilling to finish
her sentences is usually a cliche but it
fits with her character's properness and
timidness yeah so I I thought the scene
between Alison and Kristen was cool um
because as you say like Alison was
basically asking Kristen hey like is it
true that rhaenyra had sex with someone
like because uh Laris the club would
told Alison the like hey rhaenyra had
Moon tea so Alison starts to doubt you
know maybe Rainier did lie to her so she
asks Kristen
and you know just like Otto in the
previous episode was like unable to ask
viserys like
Otto was like unable to speak straight
to viserys when Otto told viserys that
Rainier hooked up with Damon Otto was
like must I say it to your grace they
were coupling behaviors Unbecoming of a
maiden like he like he couldn't say they
[ __ ] you know like he just couldn't
get the words out because he is so sort
of proper and just sort of so like
emotionally disconnected from I mean you
know like I guess with Otto there might
be a lot of sort of Trauma from the
death of his wife
um Otto is clearly still very raw about
the death of his wife we saw that when
Daemon was insulting on her and you know
like daughter like father you know
Alison also is uncapable of just saying
like hey did rhaenyra root her uncle and
because Alison sort of speaks in circles
and just sort of says oh like a sin was
committed like what whom with whom
someone knew someone biblically and
Kristen's like yeah I did it and
Allison's like oh my God like right
Allison thought that rhaenyra like maybe
something happened with Daemon but now
she finds out that raniera had sex with
Kristen and it's so interesting that
Kristen just comes out and confesses it
just like that
um which shows that you know Kristen has
has so much guilt and and so and feels
so conflicted and feels so horrible that
he broke his kingsguard Earths and had
sex with the princess committed treason
and he says yeah you know my oath has
been broken uh but please don't take my
penis
he says rather than guilding me uh
please sentence me mercifully for death
so like Kristen wants to die at this
point
um and you know that's partly I guess
because you know he told rhaenyra like
hey
um run away with me like like Chris
Christian feels basically that he cannot
continue with the status quo he cannot
continue being a king's God knowing that
he soiled his cloak like and the cloak
means so much to him because no coal has
ever had a place of this much honor like
it is the greatest accomplishment of his
life that he is a king's God and
kingsguard a sworn for life this is his
life forever and he knows that he just
cannot live with himself wearing this
cloak and knowing the cloak is a lie
having broken the oath and so he is so
torn up about that that he's like well I
have to live a different life like he
just says to Rainier hey run away with
me let's be free let's get away with it
let's get away from this oath that I
broke get get away from the guilt and
free together and Rainier is like
nah
because I don't think that the sex with
Kristen meant as much to Rainier as it
did to Kristen she didn't you know swear
an oath of Chastity and like this is the
first time she's had sex I think she
wants to try some other flavors you know
like she likes Kristen but like she is
not fallen in love with him or anything
and she also you know I think that when
she rejects Kristen here she's also
thinking about the prophecy
um because in the previous episode
viserys showed
um
viserys showed rhaenyra like hey like
the reason our Dynasty exists is to save
the world from the white walkers this is
a really big deal and I think rhaenyra
has listened to her father and rhaenyra
has accepted that like yeah I I do have
a responsibility to save the world and
also like I think she has some taste for
political power so like at the same time
that rhaenyra has constantly rebelled
against and chafed against her
responsibilities and her her
restrictions and obligations
um I think she has decided that she
wants to make the best of it and that's
why when she's walking with Lenor she's
saying like hey I get it you're gay uh
you want to [ __ ] around well that's fine
because I also want to sleep around
um so they have this very sort of modern
very very adult and grown-up and
understanding uh relationship without
they agree to have an open relationship
um which is which is interesting because
like it's interesting that rhaenyra is
so chill about homosexuality
um because like in Westeros like there
are people who consider homosexuality a
terrible sin and it's something that
that's hidden like noble people don't
openly have homosexual relationships
it's something that tends to happen on
the download like with Loris and Renly
um so it's interesting that these two
are so chill with it I mean I guess that
you know partly that might be because
they are Valyrian
um the targaryens and the valerians have
always considered themselves to be you
know a different species to lesser
humans the targaryens especially they
consider themselves closer to Gods than
to men they practice polygamy they
practice incest so they don't consider
themselves Bound by the same rules of
sexuality that everyone else are so I
guess in that respect it makes a lot of
sense that rhaenyra would not care about
homosexuality as an issue whereas it's
interesting that Corliss
um when he was talking about Lenor his
son with his wife rhaenys he was saying
that oh you know it's just a phase
Lenoir will grow out of being gay
reindeer is hard so they'll totally
she'll straighten him out uh so uh so
yeah I guess call this is more
traditional in that respect
thank you for the Super Chat from
sweetness who says uh Melos denying
viserys other treatments is very
reminiscent of paisal not treating John
Aaron properly seems like a grand
conspiracy is afoot yeah that was very
interesting wasn't it
um because you know viserys is very sick
um he seems to be like infected from
that cut in his finger that has spread
to the rest of his body
um and we saw him being treated by the
maesters Melos and Orwell
um and Melos is as we've seen before
very close with Otto Hightower
um
we've seen them you know whispering to
each other and writing writing letters
to each other and um being all buddy
buddy
um so some people are suspecting and you
know it sounds like maybe the maesters
are spying for the high Towers because
the maesters
um because the Hightower is somehow new
about corliss's plans previous episode
but yeah I mean there's a possibility
that maybe Melos is like denying viserys
the proper Healthcare
um because Orwell says hey let's give
him a herbal poultice maybe that'll fix
him and Melos is like nah nah nah
leeches all the way leeches leeches
leeches or bust
um and it doesn't seem to be working
does it like like Melos says no no like
leeches have always given his grace
Comfort but doesn't he doesn't seem very
comfortable does he it's like in episode
two I think when Melos was like oh these
maggots these maggots are the best hope
we have of saving your fingers but in
the next episode viserys lost his
fingers so Milo is a healthcare
treatment does not seem to be working
very well and there's a possibility that
maybe Melos is deliberately letting
viserys die because Melos is working
with the high towers and the high Towers
want viserys to die uh so that his son
aegon can become King instead of
rhaenyra but but that's where like I
think the plan might not make sense
because like the hightowers want aegon
to be heir so they should want viserys
to live long enough to change his mind
and say that aegon should be Heir
instead
um like I don't know if it really serves
the hightower's interests for viserys to
die while rhaenyra is still the official
Heir but I guess maybe the hightowers
might be thinking that well look we
can't change viserys's mind viserys has
his heart set on Rainier being the heir
so I guess we might as well just kill
viserys now but I mean like it might be
I still think it might be more in the
hightower's interests for viserys to
stay alive longer because then baby
aegon can grow up and you know if aegon
is older then he'll be a more appealing
heir to the throne instead of if aegon
is still a baby you know so I'm not sure
if it necessarily makes sense for the
high towers and the maesters to be
letting viserys die
um
uh yeah but but there certainly seems to
be some skullduggery a foot
um
a Taylor in the live chat says oh
viserys is still alive I thought he died
at the end no like viserys did not die
um he did like collapse to the ground at
the end of the episode and his crown
fell off his head so it's a very it's a
very bad Omen viserys does not seem long
for this world but uh but the king is
not dead yet no
thank you for and obviously like you
know viserys was coughing and sweating
and puffing throughout this episode and
like you know the valerions saw that and
they kept saying do you want to sit down
viserys like you know don't die yes not
on deal with married your your daughter
in there uh so everyone sees that the
king is like dying like he was bleeding
during the the wedding and I think that
you know because everyone sees the
viserys is dying that makes everyone
really so sort of antsy and really like
eager to prepare for conflict because
like you know rhaenys says this episode
hey like call us like when the King dies
rhaenyra's Ascension will be disputed
everyone's expecting conflict so the
battle lines are being drawn the
relationships and all of the grudges
that's all being thrown into Stark
relief thanks for the Super Chat from
Austin who says what are your thoughts
on the conversation between Ellison and
Laris also it's in front of a weirwood
yeah I thought the Weir would it the way
we're deciding interesting choice
because there is not a weirwood tree in
the red cape in
um in the main books or in the main
series and it makes you wonder well
maybe something will happen to that
weirwood tree in between now and later
um and yeah the weirwood is always
watching which which is interesting
um with Laris because it seems as though
larys is watching Laris somehow knew
that rhaenyra was given Moon tea last
episode and and Lara somehow knows about
Alison's you know doubts that he's
coming and exploiting now so I wonder if
Allison if if Laris you know has some
spies or something like we saw mazarius
buying previously I wonder how larus
knows what he knows and I liked Laris
you know comparing
um himself to a flower he was saying
that oh this is like a flower from
braavos and it's interesting that it's
thriving here well I guess he I mean
that was about Alison because you know
Allison is in the red dress the red
flower Allison is not native to this
place Alison is native to native to Old
Town and Yet Alison is is flowering and
Allison is thriving here and I guess
maybe that might have given Allison some
confidence like I guess Laris was saying
like hey Alison like you're not from
here you're not from the red cape you're
not a Targaryen you're not a dragon
rider but you can still Thrive and
flourish here in the red keep here in
the seat of power just like these
flowers flower power
um thanks for the Super Chat from
bandywine who says uh if your name is
Joffrey do not attend a wedding yeah so
uh Joffrey lawnmuth the boyfriend of
Lenor valerion uh was beaten to death by
Kristen Cole which sucks because uh
Joffrey didn't really do anything wrong
I mean he sort of did because like
Joffrey and Lena figured out that like
okay so rhaenyra wants to have an open
relationship uh who is her lover like
who is it that Rainier wants to sleep
with
um and they decided that it must have
been Kristen because Joffrey and uh
Lenor figured out that you know Kristen
was looking extremely nervous throughout
the wedding and so because of that
Joffrey came over to Kristen and said
hey I know that you and rhaenyra have a
thing you guys have a secret
relationship
I want you to know that I know
um like Joffrey said to Kristen like I
know your secret and you know our secret
so let's protect each other's secrets
you know
um which is kind of a dangerous thing to
say to Kristen because like that secret
about rhaenyra and Kristen could get
Kristen killed or gilded and Kristen is
so aware of that and so I think that you
know Joffrey kind of threatening Kristen
by saying hey I know the secret that
could get you killed yeah that's what
part of what like pushed Kristen over
the edge and it is like irrational to
attack Joffrey specifically
um but that's what he did he was just so
overwhelmed like the pain of watching
Rainier or dance with Lena
um he's just projecting all of his rage
onto Joffrey lawnmuth and it is quite
different in um it is quite different in
the books
um so they mentioned that there were
going to be tournaments
um like seven days of feasting and
tournaments to celebrate the wedding of
rhaenyra and Lena and in the books it's
during one of these ornaments that
Kristen kills Joffrey and he kills
Joffrey during a melee which is when all
of the knights fight like you're
actually meant to fight each other and
you're not meant to kill each other like
you use like uh dull weapons
um so you're not meant to murder each
other during a melee but like it does
happen like people regularly regularly
die during melees so since Kristen did
it during a melee it's sort of more
forgivable it's more excusable
um that Christian killed someone whereas
like beating a man to death in the
middle of a wedding dance is a lot more
[ __ ] up I feel like Kristen should
definitely face some consequences for
this like I don't think Kristen should
get away with murdering someone during a
wedding dance
um and you know I don't think Kristen
expected to get away with it either
because Kristen Was preparing to to kill
himself and I think it's such an
interesting choice for like Alison to
save Kristen
um from suicide I thought that was a
really good way to create a connection
between them
thanks to the Super Chat from Brian uh
and thanks for the Super Chat from
Dakota who says both murder scenes
didn't do it for me how is Cole support
supposed to walk away
um yeah well yeah I agree like I feel
like Kristen should have immediately
been like arrested for killing Joffrey
um because you know lane or the you know
the new Future King console that lane or
would want Justice Lenor would want
Kristen imprisoned or killed
so yeah I mean maybe Alison like maybe
Alison protects Kristen you know I guess
we might never know
um the aftermath of this exactly but um
yeah I agree like I feel like Kristen
should not get away with killing Joffrey
like that thanks for the Super Chat from
Brinks who says the beacon on the high
tower
yeah
yeah and that's something that they've
added as far as I remember there's
nothing in the books about the Hightower
Beacon
um glowing green but um you know Green
is is the high tower color and how and
the Hightower is the big tower in the
middle of the City Old Town
um and yeah just just highlighting for
the audience that Alison's green dress
means she is embracing her like
Hightower identity in opposition
terrania as Targaryen identity
and that's in contrast to Alison's red
dresses like last few episodes she's
very prominently been wearing red colors
which you know I guess in hindsight it
sort of tells us that that was her
um her friendship with rain era and her
alliance with the targaryens on her
wanting to work together with the
targaryens but now she's like nope
rhaenyra lied to me I'm wearing green
I'm doing my own thing thanks for the
Super Chat from bandywine who asks about
the on the next episode preview we will
discuss that at the end of the live
stream uh thanks for the Super Chat from
oath keeper who says Daemon did nothing
wrong he gave his wife a merciful end
rather than watch her suffer see that
that's an interesting interpretation and
that's what's kind of cool about Daymond
like you know like but they said in all
the interviews and stuff that their goal
with this show is that the people will
have different opinions about who the
villains are and who the heroes are it
is subjective
um and oath keeper here in the here in
the Super Chat is saying that Daemon was
innocent because he did not intend for
Reya to fall off her horse and you know
Raya was grabbing her bow she fell off
she she appears to be paralyzed like she
can't move because like she landed on
her back like it seems like she's
damaged damaged her spine
um and rhaenyra and Raya said like oh
you're walking away like you don't have
the balls to finish me off I knew you
couldn't finish she says and she calls
him a coward and so it's after she says
that the Daemon
kills her with a rock
um I I think that's a pretty [ __ ] up
thing to do personally but your your
opinion may vary maybe Daemon was being
merciful to his wife maybe he figured
that she was gonna die because she was
injured maybe she he thought that her
life wasn't worth living if her back is
broken and she can't ride anymore
in the book in the in the book it just
says that oh like Rayo just fell off her
horse while she was hunting and she
survived for like nine days but then
eventually she died
um like she got up and then she just
died
um so it seems as though in the books it
may have genuinely been an accident that
Daemon had nothing to do with or maybe
Daemon paid someone to throw Raya off
her horse
um
we definitely are meant to be suspicious
of Daemon but in the books it doesn't
say what really happened
thanks for the Super Chat from Matthew
who says the juxtaposition of Kristen
making a uh attempted suicide in front
of the weirwood versus a sham wedding
with the rat on looking yeah I thought
that was a really interesting image to
end on the the final shot of the episode
was this pool of Joffrey elonmouth's
blood with a rat eating the blood
drinking the blood we've seen a bunch of
rats throughout this episode we saw some
Rats on king viserys's bed last episode
we saw some rats sort of nibbling around
the skull of balerion the black dread
last episode and I think what this tells
us is that like all these Lords all
these Knights all these men all these
people with all their Ambitions all of
their hunger for Glory and for violence
they all are descending upon House
Targaryen like vultures like scavengers
um eating at the corpse of House
Targaryen everyone wants to get theirs
you know at the expense of the
targaryens and I think all through this
wedding like we saw all the people who
were like here to advance their own
house you know the the valerions the
Lannisters the high Towers the royces
everyone's here to get what they want at
the expense of the targaryens and
viserys is just not succeeding and
holding everything together
thanks for the Super Chat from Elizabeth
who says that Alison reached her limit
she's put up with so much and she's had
enough yeah Allison really wanted to
believe rhaenyra but um she lied and
Alison snapped and I think it also
reminds it reminds me almost of like
Cersei you know uh or like Tyrion you
know like if I can't be your friend I
will be your enemy
um I think there's a real vindictiveness
from Alison here but it's also like well
what else can she do you know like if
she can't rely on anyone if if her
father gets sent away if Rainier lied to
her like if everyone's against her it's
like well she'll just have to be her own
just like hard strong image and I really
like how you know she uses the dress
because Alison is not a man she's not a
warrior she's she doesn't have those
sort of male ways of projecting strength
she's not like a rebel and a tomboy like
rhaenyra she's a lady she's a lady-like
noble lady and so she uses dresses as
her armor she uses courtesy as her armor
she uses like the traditional feminine
ways of communication and you better
believe that a dress can send a message
and she sends a message with this dress
thanks for the Super Chat from Donovan
who's says I thought Lionel strong was
awesome seems like a cool and good dude
loved him just nodding to his son yeah
yeah it seems as though Lionel strong
has become a a trusted uh hand of the
king to viserys he's replaced Otto
Hightower as the hand of the king the
second most powerful man in the realm
and once again like he he does not
appear to be pushing his own interests
he instead is just giving viserys honest
advice like I like how viserys says oh
maybe I would have been a better King if
I had battles and like people were you
know I had an opportunity to prove
myself whereas Lionel is just like no
you idiot like it's a good thing that
you didn't have to fight any wars it's a
good thing that you have peace like it's
fine bro like I I think Lionel is um is
is the one unbiased dude in this episode
once again thanks for the Super Chat
from cc23 who says I adore this episode
as a lesbian I was sad to see that gay
relationship lost only one episode can
you please do a real Arya Stark vid like
he did with Tyrion that there is an old
shift X Arya video but it's very old and
not as good as the newer ones so yeah it
would be cool to do and a good audio
video
um we will do more character videos like
the Tyrion video
the patreon supporters voted for a Jon
Snow video so there will be a the real
Jon Snow video on alt shift X in the
future thanks for the Super Chat from
Malcolm who says do you think the dwarf
drummer was mushroom yeah so there was a
a short person playing the drums
um who maybe might be mushroom
um mushroom is the jester character
um who has all of these salacious rumors
about what went down uh in the books
like mushroom is the guy who says Alison
had sex with Damon Allison had sex with
viserys before Emma was dead Alison had
sex with
rhaenyra had sex with everyone
um mushroom just has these ridiculous
crazy stories and sometimes he's right
um and yeah there was this dwarf drama
so I wonder if he might represent
mushroom maybe maybe the co-show runner
Ryan condle did hint that we will see
mushroom or some reference to Mushroom
in this season so yeah maybe we'll see
more of the drummer eggs for the Super
Chat from Mr scar who says how was the
info about the Tea leaked yeah I agree
that's a great question how did larys
the clubfoot know about the moon tea
maybe he's working with Melos maybe he's
he maybe he's got spies in the walls
like we saw Daemon spying on the small
Council from some shadowy place maybe
Laris does that too he says that you
know I I have learned how to be
observant
um so you know I'm not invited to speak
so I learned to observe just like we saw
larus like eating the cookie listening
to the ladies
um in episode three came and sat down
with the ladies and I love this look
just just just keeping his eyes open
while all the drama is unfolding around
him storing the information away to use
later as a weapon I thought that was
wonderful
um I also just enjoyed Kristen's
discomfort his just visible pain
throughout this entire episode
um he was just refusing to make eye
contact with anyone
he you know when like a dog refuses to
make eye contact because the dog has
like you know eaten someone's uh
casserole and is just not owning up to
it like Kristen is so deeply
uncomfortable and he knows that he's
[ __ ] up and he just redirects all of
his emotions into violence against
Joffrey elonmouth
thanks for the Super Chat from rain who
says uh Daemon wearing black Allison
wearing green yeah there was a lot of
symbolism in the entrances but I think
it'll develop further uh Inquisitor says
Joffrey longmeth should have kept his
mouth shut yeah if Joffrey lawnmuth
didn't come to Kristen and say hey I
know that you had sex with raynera and
you know I you you better keep my secret
or else I won't keep your secret like
yeah if Joffrey didn't do that he would
still be alive I mean of course you know
it's it's not very fair that he got
beaten to death for this
um
I I yeah maybe Joffrey was uh not
careful enough but it's not like Joffrey
didn't know that Kristen was was so like
messed up about this so you know
um thanks for the Super Chat from jarek
who says do you think larys is more
similar to Varys or Littlefinger he does
not seem to have the realm's best
interests at heart yeah Laris seems more
opportunistic doesn't he because he he
created conflict between Alice and
Rainier by telling Alison about the moon
T and Lara said oh like I could be your
ally
um so I think Laris was creating
Conflict for his own sort of personal
gain aligning himself with Alison so I
guess he seems a bit more like
Littlefinger than Varys huh thanks for
the Super Chat from Zoe who says I don't
get why Kristen is suddenly shocked that
rhaenyra wouldn't leave the throne and
that he's to be her [ __ ] surely he knew
what he was getting into yeah I mean I
don't think Kristen or Rainier
thought it through when they had sex
last night and Kristen was very
reluctant when he had sex with rhaenyra
um so you know I I think that Kristen
like when he comes to rhaenira and says
run away with me
I I think that he knew that that was
kind of a long shot but it was sort of
his one hope like he just sort of had
this fantasy that this is the way that I
can escape from my guilt and my fear
um and when that sort of Last Hope
didn't happen uh he was he had nothing
you know that was his that he he um he's
he tried nothing and he's all out of
options you know like that was his plan
B and that was his only plan
um I think that I think and I think that
it's interesting like Kristen saying
like I'm to be your [ __ ] you know so
it's not just guilt it's not just fear
it's also Pride that Kristen was feeling
because Kristen just can't
be okay with standing there watching uh
his secret lover rhaenyra like married
to another man
um Kristen's Pride just couldn't handle
it being Rainier as [ __ ]
um so you know
he's got a very he's got a proud notion
of how he needs to be thanks for the
Super Chat from rack who says they
really need to call someone about these
rats they need an exterminator rats in
the walls rats at the banquet rat rats
in the bed
um I think it is another sign I mean you
joke but I think it is another sign that
like the castles infested with rats for
saris's house is not in order something
is rotten in the state of Denmark uh
viserys is not doing well as king
um thanks for the Super Chat from LMC
Doug who says Daemon being accused of
murdering his wife Reya and then
seamlessly transitioning to positioning
for her seat yeah I thought that was
really cool when you know Daemon waltzes
in uh he's his wife is dead at his hand
and then his wife's cousin uh this Royce
guy Gerald Royce uh comes and accuses
Daemon of murdering his cousin daemon's
wife and Damon says who are you which I
thought was such like a wonderfully rude
brutal answer like this guy's coming and
putting his heart on the line saying you
killed my cousin and Damon's like I
don't even know who you are
um and yeah oh I'm positive actively
bereft such a tragic accident like
Daemon could at least have the grace to
pretend that he's sad about his dead
wife
but just like he sort of rolls with the
accusation about the air for a day just
like he rolls with the accusation that
he had sex with Rainier Damon just sort
of rolls with the accusation that he
killed Ray or Royce
um he doesn't even try to tell people
that he's innocent he sort of wants
people to think that he's guilty you
know
um and yeah then Daemon immediately goes
into wanting uh raya's seat runestone
the castle of house Royce Daemon is like
well since Reya had no kids and since
Ray was my wife I should get her castle
runestone and it's sort of like well
does Daemon really want the castle of
runestone like does demon really want to
live in the veil which he found so
boring where men [ __ ] shape like does
Damon really want runestone or is he
just saying he does to piss people off
it's a little bit like how viserys
in episode one said you know Daemon
doesn't really want the Iron Throne like
he would be bored by the responsibility
Daemon doesn't want to be a politician
he just wants to create chaos and and
kill people and get attention in
validation Daemon doesn't want
political responsibility but in this
episode he's like oh give me runestone
just to stir up this Royce guy
um and Daemon said that after after this
wedding is over he's going to fly to the
veil and he's going to take the castle
of runestone for himself so we'll see
how that turns out thanks for the Super
Chat from Daniel who says how is viserys
gonna get it on with Alison to produce
more children the guy can barely stand I
think sometimes the last thing that
stops working is the reproductive organs
you know probably some probably
something evolutionary there
um Allison has two children with the
visares aegon and the daughter and uh
yeah we'll see how that develops thanks
for the Super Chat from Sydney who says
did anyone spot the spicy tapestries in
Alison's room there's certainly some
repressed Desires in there yeah that's
an interesting that's an interesting
idea
um
like I think that the sexy tapestries on
the walls you know it sort of speaks to
the whole life and death theme
um you know like the opening sequence of
this series is about birth and death
being intertwined and having like an
orgy in the background of every second
scene has has that sort of reminder of
you know it's all everyone locked
together in this endless cycle of life
and death that is the royal family that
is the species and you know there are
dragons in the orgy tapestries as well
which implies um
you know that the targaryens especially
have like a blood connection to the
dragons I thought it was fun that we got
to see uh more dragons this episode uh
we saw I I believe it was
um rainey's Targaryen on melis the red
dragon and uh lanor on sea smoke the
gray Dragon I mean that here
looks a little bit more like Elena than
like rainey's to me but that red dragon
must be melis the Red Queen rhaenys is
Dragon so yeah yeah that I am slightly
confused by that here
because I feel like that looks like
Lena's hair not rain is hair but I'm
pretty sure that's that's melees
rainey's the Dragon
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Isaac
who says how is Daemon George Martin's
favorite character he's got Ramsay Vibes
yeah I I feel like George Martin's
intentions with Daemon may have changed
and evolved
um because like in the original version
of this story the Rogue Prince Daemon is
described as you know being both a hero
and a villain having light and darkness
in his heart in equal parts but I feel
like the Daemon of this show and even
the Daemon of the full story
um is clearly not equally good and bad
like Daemon is very likable but he is he
he kills so many innocent people
um I don't see how you can see him as a
hero like maybe sort of an anti-hero in
some respects but yeah I I feel like
Daemon has a character certainly evolved
um in the live chat Dudu Majora says how
is a dragon rider chosen does a dragon
choose its Rider I mean we saw that
um
we saw that targaryens have dragon eggs
placed in their cradles so like trueborn
targaryens often like like the books
don't really explain this stuff fully
like we don't know exactly how this
works
um but trueborn Targaryen babies often
have a dragon egg placed in their cradle
and when the dragon hatches uh often or
almost always the dragon bonds with the
baby and they become dragon and Dragon
Rider and that's like a lifelong
relationship for the human uh humans in
the books have only ever bonded with one
Dragon but dragons live longer than
humans do so after the human dies the
dragon often gets a new Rider
um
so
so the bonding doesn't happen always
though like sometimes when they put a
dragon in the Cradle sometimes the
dragon egg doesn't hatch so the kid
doesn't get a dragon or and you know
sometimes people can claim dragons later
in life so like there are a lot of
different ways that it can happen
um it's not always consistent
um it's not super well explained but
yeah there are several ways that people
can get dragons
thanks for the Super Chat from Lovell
who says please tell me you see them
bringing the house of the Dragon Story
back closer to the events of Fire and
Blood yeah I think they're hewing pretty
close to the books I mean the books as
always have multiple versions of what
happens so like you know in the books
um it says that it gives us multiple
versions of what happened here between
rhaenyra and Kristen
um and one version of the story is that
Kristen came to Rainier and said I love
you let's run away together to the East
and Rainier said no but there's another
version of the story where before her
wedding night rhaenyra came to Kristen
naked and said hey let's bone one last
time before I'm married and Kristen
rejected her and said no I'm a
kingsguard knight I can't have sex with
you so so the books have multiple
different versions of what happened here
thanks for the Super Chat from Audrey
who says the second I saw lenor's
boyfriend I knew he would die since he
was quickly becoming my favorite
character yeah I I liked Joffrey
lawnmuth I feel like Jeffrey lawnmuth
had like slightly more personality than
Lena did honestly
um I want to see more characterization
of Lenor because like so far Lenor is
just kind of this like mild Meek guy
which you know I guess that fits his
characterization in Fire and Blood
because in Fire and Blood like it
doesn't tell us very much about Lenor
but it does say that um Lenor was
knighted two weeks before his marriage
terrain era because it was just sort of
seen as the proper thing that he should
be a knight before he marries the
princess uh which I think sort of
implies that Lenor in the books is not
much of a fighter like he's not much of
a knight
um they only knighted him out of sort of
properness and obligation rather than
him actually earning his Knighthood
um whereas in the TV show like we saw
lanor fighting on the stepstones and
riding his drag Dragon sea smoke in
battle
that's not in the books the books don't
mention lane or being involved in the
war on the stepstones the books do say
that Lenor loved his Dragon sea smoke
sea smoke was was the pride and joy of
lenov valerion
um so he's into Dragon riding but in the
books don't really mention him being a
warrior
thanks for the Super Chat from Pietro
who says I love the Trope of characters
accidentally admitting a secret because
they think another character already
knows it yeah it was uh it was it was a
bit goofy thanks for the Super Chat from
John who says we briefly saw a Bolton in
the episode one joust is there a chance
of seeing any more boltons this season
well I'm not going to spoil anything
um but but I mean don't hold your breath
for any boltons uh thanks for the
superchar from porus who says love your
content uh who is your favorite Dragon
um well we had talk about Vega in a
previous episode the oldest and biggest
Targaryen Dragon alive
I am excited and hopeful to see Vega I
thought sea smoke looks cool and yeah
I've also got mellies and we've got uh
Cyrax the yellow dragon of rhaenyra but
I think karaxi is his best boy karaxi's
is uh Daemon targaryen's dragon and he's
just got so much personality like he's
so squeaky he's got his absurdly long
penis shaped neck uh he's so weird and
ridiculous he's got like he's back legs
Wings he's he's so weird and freaky and
Moody and uh I I enjoy him very much I
think it is so great how they've given
the dragons Unique Sounds to go along
with their unique looks
it is very important because we are
gonna have to tell these dragons apart
in this story so it's good that they are
characterizing them thanks to the Super
Chat from Henry who says what was J
Harris's Legacy that Lord strong said
was so great that viserys continued so
jeheris's Legacy was peace basically
like joharis was like the first king of
Westeros that didn't cause a bunch of
wars and [ __ ] this is joharis
Targaryen he's the grandfather of
viserys and viserys inherited Jay
Harris's Throne because like the
Targaryen like the history of the
targaryens is that you know aegon the
Conqueror took over Westeros
um with Fire and Blood alongside his
Sister Wives rhenis and visenya and they
killed a lot of people like aegon seems
like a decent guy as far as people who
conquered continents go like aegon was a
good politician and aegon was good at
like creating alliances and like
creating Pace but like he started by
burning thousands of men and killing a
bunch of people and con and like sure
like according to viserys you know he
had a dream that he must take over in
order to save to save the world from the
white walkers
but he killed a lot of people and then
uh aegon's son Anis inherited the throne
and he was just a bit [ __ ] like he was
just weak he was not a good politician
he was kind of oblivious
um and the faith like rebelled against
him because of his incest marrying his
children together and like he just did
not have his [ __ ] together and he very
quickly died young possibly murdered by
his brother maegor and maegor was this
Warrior he was cruel he was selfish he
was an [ __ ] he married six different
wives and didn't produce children with
any of them so so like with Daemon
there's a bit of a you know reproductive
failure being like associated with evil
in some ways so maegor was horrible he
he took the faith to war he killed a lot
of people
um and then he died on the iron throne
and then his nephew ja Harris inherited
that inherited the throne and Jay Harris
was like the one who said okay guys
settle the [ __ ] down like calm down he
made peace with the faith that's why
they call him the conciliator
um and he he just sort of played the
right balance of showing strength but
also showing mercy and like listening
and talking but also going to war when
necessary like they say that he had a
peaceful Reign there were some Wars
there were a few little Wars here and
there but he dealt with them well
um and he made all these progresses
traveling around the Seven Kingdoms
listening to the Lords listening to the
common people he listened to his wife
the queen alisane she was very
influential created like these reforms
um that made life better for like women
and for common people so he he built
roads he built infrastructure he's like
hey like maybe we should have some
decent drinking water in this city he
just like genuinely made a lot of good
decisions he ruled for a very long time
uh and it was like the first like good
long peaceful reign in Targaryen history
and so that is the Legacy that Lionel
strong is talking about here he's saying
that you know hey like viserys like you
know maybe you didn't win any glory in
Wars maybe you didn't do anything super
cool but like you know what you
continued Joe Harris's Legacy of peace
and prosperity because despite all of
the political tension we see now
viserys's Reign was still long and
peaceful and prosperous and things were
pretty good you know relatively speaking
so that's what Lionel is talking about
when he says that viserys continued
joharis's Legacy of peace
thank you for the Super Chat from Lucas
uh and thank you for the Super Chat from
all right snail who says I thought the
problem with rainey's becoming Queen was
that her kids wouldn't be targaryens but
rhaenyra can just choose which family
her kids belong to kind of wild yeah so
that was the negotiation between
um
between Corliss and viserys where
they're saying that like okay we're
gonna marry the heir to the throne
rhaenyra Targaryen to lane or valerion
um rhaenyra is a Targaryen Lenor is a
valerion and traditionally the wife
takes the surname of the husband
um but viserys is saying yeah no like
this is the Targaryen Dynasty
um and we want to keep the Targaryen
name so like when like so like so visera
says that like okay fine like when
Rainier marries lane or she can take the
uh the Valerian name and their children
can take the Valerian name but when they
take the throne they will be called
Targaryen not valerion
so you know it's sort of like enforcing
like Targaryen Supremacy over the
valerians the targaryens are still
number one whereas Corliss kind of
wanted the valerion name on the throne
partly out of you know his pride
um but also you know that would seem to
make the valerions the new number one
house you know
um ahead of the targaryens which would
be a big shift
um
so yeah it's interesting to see that
negotiation and I thought it was funny
that you know like they talked about uh
the targaryens and the valerians are
like the two pillars the two Valyrian
families because of course the
targaryens and the valyrians are uh both
from old valyria originally which is the
dragonlords the great Empire that fell
like Atlantis and they alone have the
blood of the dragon and can ride dragons
um I thought it was funny that they said
you know we are the two pillars of old
valyria because like in the books at
least the valerians and the targaryens
are not the only
Valyrian families in Westeros there's a
family called house celtagar and they
have crabs as their heraldry and they
are also a Valyrian family they are less
powerful than the targaryens less
powerful than the valerians but they are
Valyrian and so it's so funny that
throughout House of the Dragon the
targaryens and the valerians are just
constantly saying yep we're the only
valerians that matter [ __ ] those crab
people who don't care about the Celtic
girls but the celtagas have a Valyrian
steel ax in the books which is cool so
you know very disappointing to see this
celtica Erasure once again
thank you for the Super Chat from CJ who
says I wonder if Laris and mazaria are
partnered in the business of little
birds yeah that would be cool wouldn't
it mazaria the spymaster and Laris the
clubfoot the the white worm and the
clubfoot I like how they both have like
stage names you know club foot and white
worm uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Brandon who says Braun did say that
ladies fall from their horses and snap
their pretty necks all the time it's so
sad that we saw that reality poor Daemon
what a shame that Rayo Royce died
leaving Damon the inheritor of runestone
what a goddamn shame yeah so that is the
same thing that uh Braun was planning
with his uh beloved lady wife lolis uh
because in Game of Thrones season five
Bron gets married to this uh sweet
innocent uh woman
Lola stokeworth and Braun seems to be
planning to murder her and take her
castle
which is which is sort of what happens
in the Game of Thrones books
um it does yeah these poor accidents
seem to happen to people when they are
um in line for a castle thanks for the
Super Chat from Darth Wick who says Raya
finally shows up and then instantly dies
and refuses to elaborate yeah look I
thought Raya was good like she made an
impact
you know I think that she was cool and
likable and so it meant something when
she died
um and uh yeah I think it's interesting
people's reaction to her death like a
people uh thinking that Daemon is a
monster for this
um or do they think it's an accident
that Reya died and Daemon just put her
out of her misery there are different
ways to interpret this I really enjoyed
uh when viserys was like puking his guts
out on the ship which again you know
makes him seem just sort of weak and
then Lionel has to come along and bring
the king a wet wipe to wipe up his puke
uh which reminds me of that line from
Game of Thrones uh the the king shits
and the Hand wipes is what they say
about the hand of the king like the king
creates the Miss and the hand has to
deal with it and that's what we saw with
Lionel looking out for the king's puke
uh
we got to see high tide we got to see
Elena brought up
um you know I thought it was interesting
with Otto and Allison when Otto was
saying like there will be conflict
between you and Rainier and it's sort of
like you know there's truth to that but
it's also like maybe this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy you know
and I mean none of this would have
happened if Otto didn't push Alison to
hook up with viserys like you know like
I think that Otto does come across as
sympathetic a lot of the time like a lot
of the time Otto seems like he's just
trying to do right by the realm or he's
just trying to protect his daughter like
that's how he seems in this scene but
like we've got to remember that the only
reason why his daughter is in any danger
in the first place is because Otto
pushed Alison to hook up with viserys
and the reason he did that was for the
political Ambitions of how Thai Tower so
you know as much as Otto may seem
sympathetic sometimes I think that he
put Alison in this dangerous position in
the first place
um
I thought it was interesting how viserys
was like constantly trying to avoid any
kind of political talk throughout this
episode like he tried to avoid talking
about Raya Royce he tried to avoid
talking about succession issues you know
viserys just wants people to get along
he doesn't want to deal with the
difficult issues and that allows the
issues to Fester just like the
infections in his body
uh I really enjoyed Lena valarion's line
when they arrived at driftmark and Lena
said to Alison let's let us go and
discover what might be had for breakfast
that's going to be my new line every
morning let us discover what might be
had for breakfast thanks for the Super
Chat from Andrew who says in episode 2
when everyone including Otto coward at
karaxi's I thought it was amazing how
westerling stood tall a Westeros versus
valyria moment hmm so Harold westerling
is the kingsguard Knight he
introduced each of the houses as they
walked in this episode this is Harold
westerling here
and yeah like I thought there is that
sort of constant sort of tension between
the Valyrian Dragon Riders and everybody
else
um and we got a sense of that when you
know this episode viserys announced you
know this will be the beginning of a
second age of dragons and everyone in
the hall claps and goes like yeah great
second age of dragons that sounds
fantastic but like you know the field of
fire was not that long ago you know like
thousands burned on the field of fire
you know dragons burned deceptive
remembrance the the greatest sept in
King's Landing like Dr an age of dragons
does not sound like an entirely good
thing to everybody and so when we talk
about like a grand maester conspiracy
against the dragons because in the books
there are people who claim that the
maesters have a conspiracy against the
dragons to destroy the dragons because
it's like well dragons create so Much
Death and instability and Dragons make
it impossible for anyone to Quest
question House Targaryen so when you end
up with [ __ ] like maegor the cruel
no one can do anything about it because
of the Dragons so like when visera says
this will be a second age of dragons I
think that a lot of the Lords in that
room are going uh we do not want a
second age of dragons
I thought that uh Jason Lannister when
he rolled in was uh very funny true to
form he was trying to be like this you
know slick talker and he just says this
like misogynistic thing of uh you know
women women always be late you know how
women be women getting ready with their
makeup when we men are doing the wars
women be women be making sandwiches uh
Jason's sort of like casual buffoonish
misogyny I think was funny
um and you know it is great that we've
got Jason Lannister and his brother
Thailand Lannister played by the same
actor because we get to enjoy the
contrast between them
um because while Jason is sort of this
like over arrogant Rich frat boy uh uh
Dingus Thailand Lannister seems to be
this sort of like hard-working uh
long-suffering younger brother who's
sort of doing his best politically but
doesn't have the same arrogance that his
older brother Jason does so I enjoy the
characterization
yeah women be shopping that's what Jason
was saying uh thanks for the Super Chat
from Hannah who says could the unusual
Nobles fighting and deaths represent how
the tags and viserys are causing the
moral decline of Westeros or workings
always so hands off yeah so like there
has been all this random violence
breaking out you know the the Bracken
fighting the Blackwood and the knights
fighting at the tournament and now
Kristen killing Joffrey lawnmuth at the
at the wedding dance and we've talked
before about how that indicates that you
know there's a lot of like
that there's a lot of
ambitious
um men who want to fight for Glory
but I agree that I think that that
speaks to the targaryen's failure to
impose their Authority and keep the
peace like part of the whole sort of
political contract in Westeros is that
the king is in charge in order to
guarantee peace and justice for
everybody
um the king gets the power and the
people get the peace that is meant to be
the agreement but you know all too often
the king does not succeed or uphold that
duty to provide peace and I think part
of the way that the king needs to
provide peace is by wielding Authority
like the king needs to guarantee Peace
by having the biggest army and having
the most strength and saying no one
disrupts the piece of the realm or else
I'll disrupt the [ __ ] out of I'll make
pieces of their head if they try and
break the piece the king enforces the
peace with strength and I think
throughout all these episodes viserys
constantly fails to project the strength
needed to info Force the piece and
that's partly by stuff like you know
Daemon slinks into the Hall despite the
fact that Daemon has repeatedly broken
the piece repeatedly broken laws
repeatedly created chaos of viserys has
repeatedly sent him away but Daemon
keeps on slinking in he got this big
[ __ ] grin on his face big shit-eating
grin because demon knows that he can
just get away with it over and over
Daemon fails to assert viserys fails to
assert his authority as king and I agree
that's part of why everyone disrespects
viserys's Authority by starting fights
by doing their own [ __ ] by breaking the
rules
um viserys fails in his duty as king to
keep the peace
the Super Chat from Alex who says how
did Joffrey know that rhaenyra's lover
was Kristen Cole at that point in time
only Alison knew dear Joffrey simply
guess it was Cole by his body language
at the wedding yeah I think that's
exactly what happened
um because you know Lenor and Joffrey
were discussing like you know who is
Rainier's lover like what is the deal
there and I think that they correctly
just sort of look at Kristen
um and sort of see how uncomfortable he
is because it is very obvious how
uncomfortable Kristen is so I guess they
just sort of guessed and maybe you know
when Joffrey came up to Kristen Cole and
said oh I know your secret like maybe
similar to the conversation with Alison
and Kristen Cole maybe Joffrey did not
know for sure that Kristen was the lover
but he was just sort of feeling it out
by talking to Kristen and when he was
talking to Kristen he just sort of
figured it out by talking to Kristen
that you know he was the secret lover of
nearer and you know it's sort of
interesting that that is the case
because
I don't know if Rainier even does
completely think about Kristen as her
secret lover like yeah like she was
smiling and like into him the next
morning in the previous episode but I
think that Rainier is not totally got
her heart set on Tristan like I think
that she's she's young she's a teenager
like crushes can pass quickly she only
hooked up with Kristen in the first
place because he was just the nearest
dude who she knew
um
so I I don't know if Rainier even saw
Kristen as her dude at this point
entirely I think she was open to options
like there's still tension between
um Daemon and Rainier like there's
clearly sexual tension between these two
like we see Daemon like really get up
close and personal with Rainier and
rhaenyra said like oh what if you took
me away to Dragonstone and married me
Daemon what then huh cut through my
father's Kings guard take me to
Dragonstone and make me your wife and
rhaenyra is clearly like taunting Daemon
here but I think that on some level
rhaenyra is telling Daemon what she
wants I think that rhaenyra on some
level wants Daemon and as much as she is
frustrated and angry that Daemon like
left her hanging in the sex club uh in
the previous episode I think Rainier
clearly has some desire for Daemon still
and Daemon has some desire for her so I
think that rhaenyra is still playing the
field uh despite the fact that she is
now married
the conversation that Leno and Rainier
are had on the beach
I thought it was fun this euphemism that
Rainier was using about like well some
people enjoy eating goose but some
people find Goose too greasy and they
prefer eating duck and that's Rainier's
way of saying hey I know that you're
homosexual personally I'm heterosexual
whatever it's all cool
um it's all fine we're valyrians we can
have sex with who we want and this is
based on a line in the Fire and Blood
book that says that
um
it was sort of an Open Secret that Lenor
was gay and a maester said well look you
know like Lenor might not have a taste
for women but I don't have a taste for
fish but when fish is served I I put up
with it and I eat it anyway and of
course you know fish being compared to
having sex with women is a is a
certainly a choice
um but yeah I thought it was fun the way
that they
um did that and uh speaking of fish did
you know that you can get an ALT shift X
t-shirt at standard.tv alt shift X it's
true maybe you should enjoy Goose or
duck in a alt shift X t-shirt yeah link
below yeah all right anyway thanks for
the Super Chat from Brandon Paulie and
from MZ Kim who says Reya didn't just
insult Daemon she insulted his sexual
performance oh my goodness well if you
insult a man's sexual performance then
of course he has a right to kill you is
that how it is [ __ ] hell Daemon is
very insecure about asexuality like we
saw that in the previous episode when he
stopped having rain here having sex with
Rainier and in episode one when he
stopped having sex with mazaria and yes
some men do respond with violence when
their sexual strength is questioned and
yeah I guess that is part of daemon's
aggression to Reya here
um I think that yeah men with Wounded
Pride responding with violence is
definitely one of the themes and women
responding with violence to insults to
their honor as well
um is part of it as well and you know
this like this entire story so far like
all of these episodes
is all about creating grudges and
wounded Pride like I won't spoil
anything but like this entire season is
basically like set up it's like prologue
almost you know like [ __ ] gets real
later like this is this is or the story
so far has all been about creating The
Grudges creating the relationships
created all the wounded Pride that is
going to result in an outburst and I
really enjoy the the dance like the
metaphor of a dance like this whole long
scene in The Wedding Dance where all of
these people uh take talking to each
other all these relationships being
explored all these grudges is all in the
context of this dance and I thought it
was really cool that Lenor said to
Rainier or hey like this dance is a lot
like combat
dancing is a lot like fighting and
that's very appropriate because
there is a conflict in the books that's
called the dance of the Dragons so I
think that what we're seeing here this
dance is like metaphorically the dance
of the dragons like all this all these
conversations all of this stuff it kind
of is like Warfare
thanks for the Super Chat from Vex who
says Harwin and laras's sloppy
Exposition explaining the significance
of green reminded me of when an Arya
line had to be added to the Game of
Thrones pilot explaining Jaime and
Cersei are twins yeah so so infamously
when they filmed the first episode the
pilot of Game of Thrones a lot of people
didn't get the relationships like a lot
of people didn't realize that Jamie and
Cersei were siblings when they first
watched The Game of Thrones pilot so in
the revised version of the pilot that
was actually aired they added a bunch of
extra dialogue where like there's a
there's a voiceover from Arya where she
says oh Jaime Lannister he's the brother
of Cersei Lannister and they sort of
explained stuff
I think it was not so egregious when
um Laris told break bones about like oh
the beacon of the Hightower is colored
green like I think that that is more of
just sort of an additional detail like I
I mean the point is that Allison is
wearing a green dress because house
hightower's color is green and they make
that pretty clear when Alison walks past
the Alice the Hightower camp and the
hightowers are all wearing green and
she's wearing green uh and you know
Alison was wearing red previously now
she's wearing green but yeah I think
it's fine that they added a bit of
dialogue just to make it really clear
that this is about Alison's Hightower
identity in contrast and in conflict
with her Targaryen
um the targaryens like right nearer uh
thanks for the Super Chat from
Inquisitor who says I don't know if
Daemon disliking a free-spirited and
willful woman is in character
um yeah I mean
I I
there's more than one kind of willful
personality like I I think that
Raya we saw that in like the the the few
minutes that we saw Raya she delivered
like four like really pointed barbs at
Daemon like this this first conversation
that they have in months or years Reya
immediately goes for the jugular with
Daemon she's like oh you hear the [ __ ]
some sheep oh you've been replaced by
Rainier a little girl or you can't even
finish when you're having sex or our
wedding is unconsummated like like she
is really riling him up
um and you know I I think that she feels
aggrieved by [ __ ] that Damon has done to
her
um but she's she's really like provoking
him
um and I think that you know so it's not
as simple as like Daemon just doesn't
like her because she's free-spirited I
think that there's there's history in
this particular relationship and yeah
like I guess the sex thing is seems to
be a big part of it like you know she
says our marriage was unconsummated and
like I knew you couldn't finish you
can't finish it so I guess that like
maybe on their wedding night maybe on
their wedding night Daemon was like okay
with the idea of of marrying Reya like
maybe they originally like kind of were
gonna maybe get along but maybe Daemon
felt humiliated because like he couldn't
perform on their bedding maybe he
couldn't get it up he couldn't finish or
whatever and Raya like insulted him over
it or something and maybe like that was
enough to like wound Demon's Pride but
also like part of it is just that Daemon
finds the veil boring like there's not a
lot to do in the veil and so he just
didn't want to be there and I think it's
very clear that you know Daemon has
always wanted
viserys's approval and and he's got such
a connection to his family some might
say too much of a connection with his
family in the case of rhaenyra
um so you know Daemon just did not want
to be there and I think that Daemon and
Raya insulted and riled each other up
and it was a bad time
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Delaney who says I like Lara strong
which makes me nervous because I like to
tell us a Oberon cereal and Caldera go
yeah well
and we liked Joffrey lawnmuth too
um and uh yeah it seems like no one is
safe there has been like a death or two
in almost every episode I think
thanks for the Super Chat from Jones
City who says is it just me or can
people just fast travel to King's
Landing all of a sudden uh I mean we saw
Daemon in the veil and we saw Daemon in
King's Landing but it didn't tell us how
like long
um how much time passed
um I think it may have been years since
the previous episode I mean Lena
valarion has certainly grown up quickly
uh we don't really know what the time
span is and I don't think we really need
to like I think we know that these
episodes are taking place you know a
year or two apart a lot of the time
um and there will be more time skips in
the future
thanks and yeah but yeah they have
dragons as irradiated Crow says like the
the Dragon Riders absolutely can fly
around pretty quickly and you know keep
in mind that like drift Mark which is
the valerion island is like just next
door to King's Landing and also like the
veil is not all that far from
um
from King's Landing as well if we look
at them like in Game of Thrones the
original show like there was some pretty
ridiculous stuff where people were going
from like the veil up to Winterfell to
the wall to the riverlands like people
were jumping all over the bloody
continent in Game of Thrones but in
House of the Dragon like most of the
action almost all the action so far is
happening in King's Landing the capital
here
um Dragonstone is just there and
driftmark is just here and the veil is
like up here so like it's all pretty
close by boat or by Dragon it's not like
in Game of Thrones where everyone was
like jet packing around the continent
like crazy
uh thanks to the Super Chat from Macys
who says the time Jump will happen
um
yeah well that's that's book stuff that
we might see later on
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Cassandra and from Mike who says if
viserys had let rainyra choose her
husband could Kristen have renounced his
vow or is it for life or would that have
been beneath her station so in this time
kingsguard have served for life I mean I
guess
um Luca Moore the Lusty Luca more strong
was sent to the wall and he was stripped
of his kingsguard cloak but normally it
is for life and you don't get to leave
the King's Guard to get married I think
that would be seen as highly unusual and
unprecedented I I don't think Kristen
Cole would be allowed to marry rhaenyra
um but you know occasionally Kings do
what they want
um like in Game of Thrones and in the
books when Barrister gets removed from
the kingsguard
um that had never happened before but
Joffrey did it anyway because he wanted
sandor Clegane to be on the King's Guard
and that was also
um unprecedented because
uh the kingsguard had always been
Knights but in when sand or Clegane the
Hound joins the kingsguard uh the Hound
was not a knight so he was the first
that also broke a precedent so like to a
certain extent like kings can do what
they want like if if rhaenyra convinced
King viserys like hey I want to marry
Kristen Cole then I guess King viserys
could have removed Kristen from his
kingsguard vows but it would have been
seen as highly unusual and also and also
like yeah like Kristen Cole is a
low-born person
um it's not a good marriage Alliance to
marry Kristen Cole and that would have
snubbed the valerions again so like yeah
I don't I don't think it would have been
seriously considered rainy or marrying
Chris system call
um
I am kind of confused about Kristen
Cole's like background because like in
episode one they said that Kristen Cole
is dornish but they also said that he
worked for The dondarians Who are
stormlanders fighting against the
dornish and then he in this episode I
think they said that Kristen was a
stormlander so I'm really like so are
they saying that Kristen has like a
dornish background but he like
immigrated or intermarried or like or
like somehow dornish Kristen Cole got
but like house Cole is from the storm
last I'm kind of confused about Kristen
being dornish I guess like I guess
someone in house call married a dornish
person and so Kristen is considered
dornish in that sense
um thanks for the Super Chat from
overcooked egg who says can we talk
about what set Kristen Cole off he
killed the Knight of kisses Joffrey
lawnmuth brutally his oranges got
rejected and he went crazy yeah Kristen
was super emotional he felt super guilty
he felt super afraid about breaking his
kingsguard vows like he was he was
suicidal like he was ready to kill
himself at the end of this episode
um and he's sort of one hope was saying
like hey Rainier let's run away from
this
let's run away from all these vows from
from his guilt from our mistakes let's
run away and start a new life and I
think when rhaenyra said no Kristen was
like [ __ ] like I've got nothing and so
he confessed to Allison and he said like
please kill me quickly
that was the best Kristen was hoping for
so so he is you know wildly emotional
state super self-destructive State and
then when Joffrey elonmouth came along
and said hey I know your secret and he
sort of implies that like hey like I
might I might tell people that you broke
your vows I might you know ruin your
secret I think Kristen sort of
redirected a lot of his emotion a lot of
his fear his anger his all of his guilt
and he just sort of expressed his
feelings uh with with his fists by
beating joffre longmuth to death and you
know sometimes that is something that
men do and it's something that
um people do sometimes is that when they
have a lot of feelings and they don't
know how to express them they express
them through violence and that's you
know I mean in the context of Christian
Cole being a knight the only thing that
Kristen Cole has ever been good at is
fighting you know like fighting is how
Kristen got onto the kingsguard fighting
is how he won Glory like everything he
knows everything thing he is is a
fighter and so I think when he's given a
big old bag of feelings that he doesn't
know how to handle he's like well I will
Express this the only way I know how
with me Fists
he's not a smart guy he's not a smart
guy
Enoch in the live chat says that Kristen
isn't dornish they said in the first
episode that he is dornish and they've
said in like the behind the scenes stuff
the Christian is dornish I guess that
he's like part stormlanders part dornish
Razzie F in the live chat says that the
dornish marcher Lords are stormlanders
that yeah I mean yeah like it's in the
Borderlands the March the marches are
the Borderlands between the stormlands
and Dawn so I guess there would be like
into marriage and stuff going on there
that that makes sense
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Brinks
who says what color does the higher
Tower glow
um is Hot D confirming the Hightower
maester conspiracy I think there was
clearly an understanding between Otto
Hightower and Melos especially like in
the scene where King viserys told Otto
um that the valerions
proposed marriage
um and Otto and Melos had these very
sort of like knowing looks between each
other
um and I think that was definitely
indicating that like there's an
understanding between Otto and Melos and
they're working together like there were
some real glances passing between them
um but you know and I think that they're
just basically trying to support
um aegon Targaryen Otto's grandson as
the heir to the throne but whether
they're also trying to let viserys die
or whether they're trying to work
against dragons in general there's a lot
of open questions you know are they
spying on people through the letters
there's a lot of open questions with the
Mesa conspiracy I think
um bln in the live chat says how many
generations are there between this and
the Mad King uh it's a bunch it's a
bunch after this particular ferocus goes
down
um there's like a uh there's a bay law
that well there's a dayron there's a
king dayron there's a king Balor there's
a king viserys there's a king aegon
there's a king
dayron there's a king Aries there's a
king Mica there's a king aegon the fifth
there's a king jeharis and then there's
King aerys the Mad King and then there's
King Robert and there's King Joffrey and
then there's King tommen
um so yeah it's it's a bunch of time
it's like
170 years or 180 years no it's like a
yeah it's like 185 years from now until
Game of Thrones so there's a lot there's
a lot more targaryening to come but we
know that like in uh for a long time
like at the time of Game of Thrones
there's no dragons
um so something happened in between now
and then so you've got to wonder uh what
what happened thanks for the Super Chat
from 20th who says the beginning of of
Otto's speech was brilliant also the
size of Vega well we'll talk about the
trailer later thanks for the Super Chat
from Brazen who says the young maester
Orwell offered a better solution for the
cuts but was shot down by the grand
maester yeah maybe the maesters and
Melos are trying to deny good health
care
um thanks for the Super Chat from Alex
who says I love you bro I aspire to be
your berserk counterpart who would you
rather be Robert or viserys oh
um I mean Robert is a worse person than
viserys like viserys is not very good at
anything
um but he does at least try to do the
right thing whereas Robert was very
happy to just marinate in alcohol and
just eat himself to death and he was
pretty horrible to Cersei I mean Cersei
is a horrible person but like Robert
like hit Cersei and like had sex with
her like raped her when she didn't want
to have sex and you know Robert is a
violent person and you know that that
sort of makes sense in terms of his
character because you know in a similar
way to what we were saying with Kristen
Cole like Rob Robert has only ever been
good at violence and that's the only way
he gets anything good in life so
violence is all he knows but yeah Robert
is a worse person than viserys I mean I
think that in the books viserys is worse
than how we're using the show like
show viserys is more of a like viserys
actually tries in the show whereas in
the books they talk about viserys mostly
just letting Otto do all do all of the
politics for him and viserys also like
eats a lot and becomes very fat later in
life
um whereas in the show viserys is not
quite as apathetic he's not quite as
self-destructive he's more just sort of
hapless and unsuccessful despite his
best Ambitions uh so yeah I think
viserys is a better person than Robert
um I think that Robert probably has more
fun than viserys so maybe it would be
more fun to be Robert
thanks for the Super Chat from unsourced
wall radio who says I don't understand
why folks are mad at Kristen that
Joffrey guy was asking to die borderline
blackmailing a King's Guard yeah I don't
think Geoffrey realized
um how dangerous
uh he he was being when he you know told
Kristen I know your secret but I mean
you know like you can't blame Joffrey
for Kristen beating him to death like it
was a mistake to tell Kristen I know
that you had sex with rhaenyra but I
mean I think Joffrey was thinking that
like Kristen could be chill about this
like Joffrey and Lenor have managed to
be chill about their relationship like
there are you know making out in the
sand dunes like and and you know Corliss
knows that Lenora is gay and rhaenys
knows that he's gay and Rainier knows
that he's gay like it's sort of an Open
Secret so I think that you know
Lino and Joffrey made the mistake of
assuming that Kristen would be a would
be as chill as they are about having a
sacred Affair but Kristen is just
anything but chill there's there's
nothing worse than than someone who
takes themselves this seriously you know
and I mean the tragedy of all this is
that
his crime was love his crime was having
sex you know and and why is that so bad
and like like we said in the video like
that is what Ariane Martel says because
in the books there's this character
called Ariane Martel who has sex with
this kingsguard Knight called Iris
oakhart this is art by magali vilnuv and
um
and Ariane says like you should not be
ashamed of having sex with me you should
be ashamed of serving King Joffrey and
serving King Domin like you should be
ashamed of all these wars and all this
violence and all this [ __ ] that you
have participated in you should not be
ashamed of having sex and making love
that that that should be fine and that's
partly like the the dawnish
um culture because the dornish culture
is like more relaxed about sexuality and
more relaxed with having paramours
whereas all these uptight bloody
westerosi Knights are all like yeah I
don't mind killing people but if I have
to make love to someone oh there's gonna
be trouble then it's like really so
partly this is George Martin like
criticizing this honor System and
criticizing this system that is built on
violence but won't allow love and of
course you know like the logic of all of
this
um you know sexual control is that the
whole notion of like medieval dynasties
in inheriting power is based on you know
marriages and agreements and sexuality
being controlled in women's bodies being
controlled that is the foundation of
this political system
um and what we're seeing is that when
you when you base an entire political
system on people keeping their junk to
themselves sometimes there's problems
because people have feelings and people
have sexual desires and this show is all
about exploring the consequences of a
political system that is based on
an impossible degree of control over
people's hearts and junk
give her the Super Chat from Beth who
says I want coal eaten by a dragon and
not in a pretty way
oh I love everyone forming their
opinions on whose side they are on uh
thanks for the Super Chat from
non-dominant who says sir down of house
bad
Kristen is down bad thanks for the Super
Chat from Peter who says what do you
think of the overall lack of fantasy
elements in the show so far apart from
the occasional Dragon I'm missing magic
dark prophecies presence of mysterious
Gods slash beings seems like more of a
political drama
I mean Game of Thrones has always been
mostly a political drama with occasional
flickers of magic that's how George
Martin likes it
um I think that in some ways House of
the Dragon has been more magical than
Game of Thrones was like it's only been
four episodes and we've already seen
like a secret Prophecy with the prince
that was promised talking about white
walkers and we've seen like viserys
having prophetic dreams about his son
um and we've seen all sorts of dragon
stuff and you know we saw the white
heart appearing to Rainier which felt
very very much like a sort of a mystical
Omen you know Supernatural or not
um and what we saw in you know Game of
Thrones was a slowly Rising amount of
magic like the first season of Game of
Thrones had pretty much no magic on it
until Daenerys hatched those dragons and
survived the fire and stuff there was a
gradual increase in the amount of magic
and maybe we'll see something like that
in House of the Dragon but but I will
say that you know House of Dragon the
story of House of the Dragon it is
focused more on human drama and
political drama and there's a there
there's a there's a fuckboat of dragons
as well but like you know I don't expect
too much Expelliarmus and Avada cadaver
ing in there so yeah it's not a super
magical story
uh thanks for the Super Chat from mother
Nix who says maybe Melos is keeping
viserys an invalid instead of outright
killing him to keep him weak yeah I
think that's a good theory for a
potential like Hightower maester
conspiracy like maybe they're not trying
to kill viserys they're just trying to
make him easy to manipulate because as
long as viserys is super weak and
reliant on the maesters he's sort of
easier to manipulate so maybe they are
hoping that when he's weak they'll be
able to sort of seize the Reigns of
power and make aegon the air yeah I
think I think that's a reasonable
interpretation
um
because yeah like it wouldn't be without
precedent for a king to be like sick or
indisposed and while he's indisposed
maybe the hand of the king or the Regent
or whoever would be able to sort of
change things and to maneuver in such a
way as to make aegon the air
uh thanks for the Super Chat from game
inspection who says do you feel that
assumption is a big theme in the story
characters act on assumptions
yeah yeah that's a good point because
you know we sort of had Kristen
confessing to Alison on the assumption
that Alison already knew that Kristen
had sex with rhaenyra when she actually
didn't know that
um I I think that you know like
assumption like I think like the failure
to communicate is definitely part of
this story
um you know I mean Daemon and viserys is
a big part of that
um like you know and there's sort of
assumptions around like the air for a
day thing when viserys sort of assumed
that Daemon was insulting viserys by
referring to his dead baby Balon as the
heir for a day when maybe viserys didn't
do that and you know people assume that
Daemon killed Raya Royce and people
assume all sorts of things
um I I think what that ties into is like
the tragic failure to communicate like
people fail to understand each other and
that leads to conflict
thanks for the Super Chat from
shinoblast who says did we just see
mushroom
um yeah so there was that dwarf drummer
who might be the jester from the books
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Rahul
who says why change the only two
actresses they build up worst episode
this season says Rahul
um yeah so you know I we'll discuss the
actor changes later on thanks for the
Super Chat from
tank who says I don't think the maester
conspiracy is about the high Towers I
think it's about killing the dragons
well that's what a character says in
book four of Game of Thrones uh Jake in
the Super Chat says that viserys has
leprosy according to his actor I didn't
say that I don't know what he's got but
he seems very unwell thanks for the
Super Chat from Winterfell forever who
says Daemon has all the signs of being a
sexual sadist one who can't get it up or
consummate unless he's dominant and
inflicts pain on his partner can't
fathom how so many fangirls find him hot
I think that if Daemon Targaryen was
played by anyone other than Doctor Who
he would probably be less liked
um I don't see any evidence of Daemon
being a like a sadist sexually but um
yeah we have seen him being sexually
frustrated a lot for sure thanks for the
Super Chat from Seven who says love the
look of high tide like Mont saint
Michelle in France a castle on the water
for the Sea Lord yeah this is the castle
that um call us for Larry on built to
replace the sort of older Castle they
used to be just like a driftmark castle
but it was sort of old and drafty and
damp so call this is like [ __ ] it I'm
going to use my wealth to build a new
cool castle
and I love how we got to see all of
corliss's like trophies and souvenirs
from all of his travels he's got this
like giant like nautilus shell or
something in the background which is
super cool and he got like the crab
feeders mask uh he he placed it as a new
trophy among all of his other trophies
so Corliss is very proud of his
accomplishments and I liked seeing all
of his uh another mask for his
collection all of his cool stuff
um I liked how we got to see the drift
the Driftwood Throne which is the Throne
of the of the valerion Lords and the
throne was supposedly given to the
valerions by
um by the Merlin King because there are
bloody mermaids in the lore of Game of
Thrones seemingly uh yeah I love that
giant shell that is very cool that feels
quite sort of fantasy e to me like I
don't think there are
um seashells that big in the real world
far as I know so I really enjoy his
trophy room it gives it gives us a sense
of who Corliss is
thanks for the Super Chat from Rhys who
says maybe the weirwood's death calls
the white walkers ooh because yeah like
we did see the weirwood tree in this
episode and um it is weird to see a
weirwood tree in the red keep because
there isn't one in the books and uh and
Rhys is saying that maybe the death of
the weirwood is the reason why the white
walkers came because it is still a
mystery in the books and the show why
the white walkers turned up after all
these thousands of years of of not being
around what caused the white walkers to
come and there's a lot of different
theories maybe it was the birth of the
prince that was promised maybe it was
the stocks leaving Winterfell maybe it
was the death of the Dragons maybe it's
just the natural seasonal magical Tides
changing
um maybe it's a promise being broken
maybe it's something about maybe it's
lyanna Stark being buried in the
Winterfell Crypts there's a million
different theories on why the white
walkers came now maybe because there's
no longer a Targaryen on the throne lots
of possibilities
trees are white walker repellent says
vangpal maybe maybe
um thanks for the Super Chat from Payton
who says shouldn't Kristen get in a lot
of trouble for murdering Joffrey
Monmouth yeah I think he should but a
lot of people have been getting away
with a lot of stuff under King viserys
so it would not be the first time that
someone you know it's like Daemon has
gotten away with all sorts of [ __ ] so
yeah I think Kristen should be punished
thanks for the Super Chat from sashin
who says knowledge is power power is
power yeah that's an interesting
comparison because like in
um
Game of Thrones season two
Peter Baelish said to Cersei that you
knowledge is power I know things I can
control things because I have knowledge
and Cersei was like [ __ ] you like Power
is power I have the power of violence
and the power of violence beats
knowledge every time so [ __ ] you little
finger and yeah I guess that is a bit
similar to like when
um when joffre lawnmuth comes up to
Kristen and says I know your secret I
know your secret about how you you had
sex with Rainier and in a similar way to
Littlefinger uh Kristen says no [ __ ] you
I I don't respect the power of your
knowledge I respect the power of my
fists and then he beat lonmouth to death
so yeah I agree there is a parallel
there
um thanks for the Super Chat from gosh
who says very proud of Daemon for not
just starting to kill those randoms with
dark sister for no reason when the brawl
began
that's true that that shows an unusual
amount of restraint
for Daemon Targaryen that that he was in
a situation of violence and he was not
the most violent person there that
Daemon did not murder a bunch of his
Rivals despite having the opportunity
this is this is a conflict that Daemon
was not the instigator of
like that's the thing like I think
Daemon is getting a run for his money in
terms of being the most violent chaotic
[ __ ] in the room because normally
Daemon is the guy who starts all the
fights and Daemon is the guy who starts
the [ __ ] but for once there was someone
stupider and more violent than Daemon
was and it was Kristen Cole which you
know what will what potential
relationship is there between Kristen
and Damon you know like they both have
been like sometime lovers of rhaenyra
um Daemon and Kristen are both violent
proud arrogant dudes and you know like
like like Lenor is a fighter and Harwin
is a fighter and there's a lot of dudes
with big swords and big energy in the
room and uh I mean talk about dragon
energy
daemon's got it thanks for the Super
Chat from Wonga who says the Raya Royce
scene felt like they were spamming the
camera button in uh Red Dead Redemption
2 cinematic mode I'll uh I'll I'll I'll
I'll leave that for the game as to
interpret thanks for the Super Chat from
Michael who says thoughts on
lightbringer being aegon's dagger and
the prophecy of Nissan
uh yeah all right well
last episode we had the uh quote-unquote
cat Spore dagger being placed in the
fire and it had an inscription from
aegon's prophecy and none of that is in
any of the books that's a show invention
um but what it might maybe connect to is
the idea of lightbringer in the Game of
Thrones books which is the sword that is
expected to be used by the chosen one
the hero Azor ahai to defeat the white
walkers uh and you know in the books
there's this whole Nissan story about
the hero killing his beloved wife in
order to forge the sword that will save
the world
um and I guess some people are
speculating that in some sense the
catspore blade might play the role of
lightbringer because the cat's poor
blade that Arya uses to kill the night
King sort of plays the role of
lightbringer I mean I think that if
there's a Nissan moment in the Game of
Thrones show it's when Jon kills
Daenerys
um that is like the hero killing his
brother covered wife the only trouble
with this in the show is that
um John kills Daenerys after the white
walkers are defeated so like it doesn't
seem to connect I think that that is
something that will be very different in
the books
um so is the cat's poor blade
lightbringer yeah like I guess like I
think Arya might be lightbringer if
anything or the dragons might be
lightbringer but yeah yeah yeah I I'm
not a huge fan of the catsport dagger
stuff because like I I don't see how it
fits with the law in the books like I
think it's mostly just a visual symbol
that they're using just to indicate that
you know the stakes are high there is an
apocalyptic threat the targaryens are
important I think that's probably all
it's meant to be as far as the show goes
but um we'll see how we'll see how it
develops uh thanks for the Super Chat
from Devon the Doppler who says when
they zoom in on the weirwood tree face I
always got the feeling that bran slash
the three-eyed Raven is watching
whatever's happening yeah that's a good
point because like in the scene with the
weirwood there is a moment where we see
the face of the Heart Tree we see the
Weeping weirwood face which is which is
in all the godswoods
um and yeah that was a really like
distinct moment of oh the weirwoods are
watching which we said in the previous
old shift x video didn't we
um and there is reason to think that
Brian Stark or the three-eyed Raven
three-eyed Crow blood Raven uh might be
watching because there is a bit of a
timey wimy element with the weirwoods
isn't there uh because bran saw through
time in Game of Thrones season six he
saw like hodor's origin story through
time and space so it's good that we've
got a Time Lord on hand in Matt Smith to
help us through all of this time travel
stuff um and there are a few moments in
the Game of Thrones books when there's a
bit of time travel Shenanigans like um
bran speaks to Theon through the
weirwood trees and it seems like that
might be a bit of a time travel thing
like future bran is talking to present
Theon bran also talks to Jon Snow
through like a weirwood dream
um so yeah like there is a bit of
tomiwamy stuff so my point is that it is
plausible
um that Brian Stark and bloodraven and
other green seers could potentially be
watching the things that happen uh in
front of the weirwood tree in the red
keep and it would not be crazy if there
was some kind of
um intervention there some kind of
whisper from the old gods so uh you know
there's definitely potential with that
we would trade there yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Sodom who
says who threw lane or on the table who
kept him away yeah so when The Big Brawl
started
um Kristen attacked uh uh Joffrey
lawnmuth but we don't see exactly what
happened like there was this big scrum
and then Lenor got like thrown onto the
table out of the way I guess it's
possible that that was just like Kristen
knocking Lenor to the side so that he
could attack attack Joffrey or I mean
maybe Joffrey was throwing lane or aside
so that you know in order to protect his
boyfriend
um yeah it looks like Lenor is like
shoving Kristen here
so you know I guess Kristen started it
and Lena tried to fight back but he was
tossed aside and then Kristen killed
Joffrey so [ __ ] up just beating him to
death with his fists Jesus Christ I'm
pretty sure you would like break your
fingers if you punched someone in the
head enough times to turn it into into
[ __ ] uh uh
mush it was like that ridiculous moment
where um Jon Snow beat Ramsay to death
uh in Winterfell which was one of one of
my less favorite bits in The Game of
Thrones show personally because he
punched him like 30 times it's like like
really do we really need really that
would do as much damage to your hands as
to his face anyway
um thanks for the Super Chat from Amber
who says does King viserys have
grayscale what was that yeah it did look
like there was some sort of weird stuff
on his arm like his arm is looking a bit
weird maybe that is like the like the
poultice like the treatment that they
might be giving him
um but then again Mela said nah just
give him the leeches I guess that's just
like infected gangrenous skin is what
that is like it may be that viserys is
like repeatedly getting more and more
cuts on his body
um from
from the Iron Throne
um
so it's possible that that is is what's
contributing to his skin being all bad
but yeah I think he's just got some deep
bad infection I don't know if the
specific disease really matters uh the
the point is that he's dying I don't
think it's grayscale I mean the thing
about grayscale is that it's contagious
I mean there are different forms of
grayscale but if like viserys's
grayscale was progressing I think he
might be infecting other people with
gresco I I don't think it's Greco I
think the only reason the crab feeder
had the grayscale was to make him look
cool thanks for the Super Chat from Levi
who said do you think Joffrey said
something else to Kristen that finally
set him off or was it just a combination
of everything that happened my
interpretation is that Kristen was just
so emotional and so overwhelmed with
guilt and fear and he was suicidal and
it's just like he just did not know what
to do with his feelings and since he is
a warrior he's a man of violence
violence is all he knows that's how he
expressed his feelings that's how I
interpret it
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Dopey
Dragon who says many blessings to
rhaenyra and Lenor may they have many
children I hope they have a great
wedding thanks for the Super Chat from
Kevin who said did you notice a hints of
the light of the seven song during
Allison's entrance it was a rather green
scene during Game of Thrones as well
yeah so what Kevin is saying is that uh
we we heard the song Faith of the seven
or light of the seven
um in Game of Thrones season 6 episode
10 when Cersei blew up the Baylor sept
with wildfire and you're right there was
a lot of green going along in that shot
just as there is a lot of green when
Alison walks in in her green dress what
would happen if Alison got her hands on
some Wildfire if Alison got her hands on
some Wildfire I think rhaenyra would be
in danger of getting singed uh thanks
for the Super Chat from SK who says does
this mean that little Christy MC Chris
Christian Cole is an old gods worshiper
yeah I do think it's a curious choice
that Kristen went to the godswood and
the weirwood tree in order to commit
suicide I I would think that it would
make more sense for Kristen to go to the
sept of the faith of the seven because
stormlanders and dornish
follow the faith nor the old gods
generally and the sept is also a place
where Alison goes you know and the sept
could be in the red keep like there is a
royal sept in in the red cape I think
um so yeah I think it's an interesting
choice and like with weirwoods there's
always the undertone of blood sacrifice
um because you know in the books they
talk about how weirwood trees
um
the first man used to make blood
sacrifice to the weirwood trees like the
Wayward trees are like beautiful and
they're sacred but they're also kind of
terrifying and monstrous and
manipulative And Hive Mindy and evil
um and I really love this art by Lauren
K Cannon of a weirwood tree a weirwood
tree full of Bones because there was
this ancient practice where the first
men would put the corpses of their
enemies onto the weirwood tree as an
offering and the blood of their corpses
would feed the weirwood tree
um there's bones and corpses feeding the
tree and the trees are feeding off death
and they are zombie trees and they're
petrified trees and it's all very sort
of dark an ominous and I think that when
Kristen is preparing to commit suicide
before the weirwood tree he is you know
gonna give his blood to the tree you
know and I think that there is a sense
of like living on in the tree because
the old gods are the spirits of the Dead
living on inside the weirwood hive
moment
so hell like maybe Kristen is performing
like a little bit of a religious
self-sacrifice to the old gods here
because it would not be the first time
that a you know a non-stark a
non-northerner a non-first man
um would would do something before a
tree like that because in uh Game of
Thrones season one episode seven Samwell
tarly who is from the reach says [ __ ] it
I'll I'll pray to the tree I'll swear my
ninths Watch oath before the weirwood
tree even though that's not his religion
um he chooses to forsake his father's
gods and pray to the weirwood instead
because he didn't get any he didn't get
any support he didn't get any love he
didn't get any validation from from the
faith of the seven so he turns to the
weirwoods instead so maybe Kristen on
some level is doing a similar thing he's
like well I've I've [ __ ] up I've done
goofed I failed I broke my Earths
um my kingsguard Oaths which were
probably sworn in like a faith of the
seven in fashion
so maybe I will turn to the mercy of the
old gods instead that yeah that would
not be a crazy or unprecedented thing to
do I think that's a that's a cool
possibility
um thanks for the Super Chat from Elena
who says honestly can't stand Alison you
seduce Rainier is Dad viserys behind
Rainier is back and then blow up when
she lies to you about something that's
none of your business
yeah I mean there's certainly a world
where Alison did not get angry at
Rainier in the previous episode like it
is an interesting reaction in this scene
when Alison like hears the rumor that
raniero hooked up with Damon and her
reaction is Fury at her friend when like
Alison equally could have come to
rhaenyra and said like hey girl like
tell me about last night like I hear you
had a fun night tell me all about it
like wow cool like how was that how was
that Uncle Wang girl
um but instead she was really like
aggressive and and cold and it's like
well you know maybe if Alison approached
Rainier differently it wouldn't have
been so bad and yeah I mean like you say
like is Alison really one to talk given
what happened with you know Alison
getting together with viserys behind
Rainier is back and I mean you know
viserys told Alison not to tell rhaenyra
about their meetings so Alison was
obeying her King and she was obeying her
father Otto and so you know I think it's
you know like it is sad that Alison
didn't tell rhaenyra about her
relationship with viserys but like it
makes sense I think
um but like yeah I mean you can make the
argument that like Alison broke
Rainier's Heart by secretly having this
relationship with viserys and not
telling her and in the same way
um you know rhaenyra felt betrayed that
that Alison felt betrayed about Rainier
but it's like well you sort of did the
same thing so maybe Ellison shouldn't be
so angry with Rainier but I think part
of the context there is that you know
Alison feels so trapped with like her
her life as viserys's wife and she feels
so sort of lonely and and cold and she's
got these horrible like
obligatory sex scenes with viserys and
like she looks she looks so sad whenever
she's holding her baby it's so sad like
there was a shot in this episode as well
where where Allison was holding her baby
and she was just looking so just tired
and just down
um
so I think that all of those feelings
are sort of part of why Allison is angry
at Rainier you know like I you know this
story is about people making just like
emotional decisions so like you know you
can't expect everyone to be totally
rational and and enlightened all the
time
um it's very much about grudges and
heartbreak and lust and ambition that is
that is what this is about and yeah
elephant is about Duty Alison is
religious there's a lot of reasons why
Alison would be mad at Rainier
thanks for the Super Chat from habub and
from Sam and from William
who's and from Mason from wilberger go
check out will Burger's Elder Scrolls
videos will Berger says another happy
wedding can we talk about Demon's need
to be powerful in all his relationships
his sexual dysfunction seems to be
related to that
yeah I agree I mean that that's what the
show Runners said in the previous
episode that like
part of the reason why Daemon stopped
hooking up with rhaenyra was because
Daemon felt like he was no longer in
control of the situation and he felt
threatened by rhaenyra's enthusiasm and
passion
so I think Daemon feels like you know
for him to have sex he feels like he
needs to be in charge which almost if if
I were to speculate haphazardly like
maybe Daemon had a bad sexual experience
once maybe he was sexually assaulted and
he was in a situation where he didn't
have control and maybe he was
traumatized by not having control and
maybe Daemon feels like he needs to be
in control because of some traumatic
thing that happened to him that there's
some wild unfounded speculation for you
but yeah like the showrunners have
talked about the idea that Daemon needs
to be in control and I think that Raya
Royce is not someone who would have
submitted to daemon's control
um and that's why that's part of why
Daemon sort of failed sexually with
rhaenyra with Reya and with rhaenyra
perhaps but yeah I mean it's um it's
ambiguous it's interesting
thanks for the Super Chat from iknuiki
who says Jason Lannister thinks his
smart mocking women in front of rhaenyra
and the King because Lannisters are just
so condescending yeah a comparison I
wanted to make was between Kristen Cole
and Jamie Lannister
because Jaime Lannister is also a
talented Warrior who
becomes a kingsguard and breaks his
kingsguard vows in Jaime's Case by
hooking up with his sister Cersei uh and
you know Kristen is similar in that how
he breaks his vows hooking up with
rhaenyra and I think that you know when
Kristen is is saying like you know I
don't want to soil my cloak I don't want
to be your [ __ ] like I think in a way
Kristen is saying I don't want to be
Jamie and you know Kristen doesn't know
Jamie Jamie comes much later but like
what kind of a life would Kristen live
if for the rest of his life he was a
King's Guard knowing that he had
it was a lie knowing that he broke his
oath knowing and being used sexually by
Rainier like wouldn't that make you
better wouldn't that make you cynical
wouldn't that make you like Jaime if you
were in that situation like what kind of
a person would you become wearing this
proud Noble kingsguard armor knowing the
whole time that you besmirched that
armor you know and obviously you know
you can argue that it shouldn't matter
that that false construct of like
Chastity and kingsguard is is just
destructive and dumb anyway uh there's a
long history in the real world of like
organizations that that preach Chastity
not following the rules of Chastity and
sometimes doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] as a
result uh you know I think that living
living the king's God as a lie would be
a really messed up thing to do and we we
saw how that [ __ ] with Jamie and I we
can imagine that Kristen might have been
put in a bad situation but obviously
like you know the way that Kristen
reacted this episode was was was even
worse you know killing yourself rather
than living a lie I you know is the only
thing worse you know anyway
um thanks for the Super Chat from Eric
who says Raya Royce didn't just fall her
horse fell on her I like the setup of
the fight
yeah yeah well I think there's
interesting ambiguity with Reya and
Daemon you know like what were daemon's
intentions here uh you know she reached
for the bow before
Daemon stepped forward
um it sort of reminds me in Game of
Thrones season four when
Tyrion approaches Shay
what was shade draws a knife and then
Tyrion strangles her to death so it's
sort of this thing of like can you argue
that Tyrion was defending himself can
you argue that Daemon was defending
himself
uh whereas in the books Tyrion totally
just murdered the [ __ ] out of Shea just
cold-blooded murder like there was no
weapon in the books when Tyrion killed
Shea so I sort of disliked that change
in the in Game of Thrones anyway thanks
for the Super Chat from wealthwolf who
says ladies don't you hate it when your
lover commits a hate crime against your
husband's lover and doesn't even have
the decency to commit supuku afterwards
thank you for the input wealthwolf uh
thanks for the Super Chat from heart 420
Weed number who says Daemon can't get it
up because he's getting that spicy
noodle from caraxi's well look I mean we
have seen murals in this episode of
dragons having sex with targaryens it
would not be unprecedented thanks for
the Super Chat from Chris from Marek and
from Jen who notices that Daemon did not
stand up in acknowledgment of Allison
coming in in her green dress
thanks for the Super Chat from talk who
says could Laris be skin changing into
the rats like bloodraven with the crows
now that is the theory I like talk
wheeler yeah because Lara somehow knew
about the moon tea that Melos gave to
rhaenyra how did he know there are all
sorts of hints and suggestions about
like there's secret passages and the red
keep there are spies there are little
birds lots of different you know the
walls have ears the wheelwoods are
watching you know there's lots of
different ways to listen in on
conversations and Lara strong is an
observant observant man maybe he's a
skin changer and he's walking into these
rats that we've seen throughout the
series
um it's not crazy I mean like you know
uh bloodraven was a skin changer
um he was the son of a Blackwood and the
blackwoods have the blood of the first
man so it's not just Starks and not just
Northerners who have skin changing Warg
blood it's potentially anyone with like
first man blood I mean you know the
royces house Royce
um are a first man house the first men
are like the uh first human ethnic group
in Westeros before the Andals arrived
and then the targaryens arrived and the
and the roina arrived there's been like
multiple waves of migration to Westeros
um and you know I guess it's plausible
that I mean I mean the strongs are like
an ancient are the Strong's first men I
don't remember off the top of my head
um but they're certainly an ancient
house it's very plausible that the
strongs could have first no yeah no the
strongs are Andals I think but it is
very plausible that you know there might
have been some intermarriage with some
first men there might have been some
intermarriage with the blackwoods since
they're in the riverlands I think
there's definitely possibilities that
Lara strong could have
could have a bit of skin change of blood
like bran like bloodraven
um there's no proof in the books of
larys doing that but I would say that
there's there's some room in there you
know there's some possibilities larys is
a mysterious dude so we'll find out
we'll find out more about him as The
Story Goes On
thank you for the Super Chat from Mark
who says why did Kristen do what he did
in the end was the subtext that Lena's
boyfriend was blackmailing him and he
didn't want to be Rainier as a side dick
yes lenor's boyfriend Joffrey lawnmuth
was blackmailing Kristen by saying hey I
know your secret so you better not tell
our secret or I'll tell your secret that
you boned the princess so yeah like
partly it was a reaction to being
blackmailed but I don't think that
Joffrey really meant it in that super
hostile way I think Joffrey was mostly
just saying like hey like I'm in the
same boat as you like we both are side
pieces here you know we are both of the
secret lovers of The Princess and the
King consort uh or future king consort
respectively so I you know I think
Joffrey was trying to be like chill
about it like that there was a bit of a
thread there but I think that he was
mostly trying to be like hey we're in
the same boat but Kristen decided to
react by beating him to death so yeah
um thanks for the Super Chat from Jess
who says interesting tension between
Lena and Damon yeah I think they had a
dance there I really want to see more
from Lena Lena
um valerion
she has like grown up a whole bunch uh
we saw her talk about breakfast at high
tide that's about as uh that's about as
much as we've seen from her uh but you
know just to be clear
this is Lena valarion and she was the
little girl who viserys uh uh declined
marriage to in episode two this is this
is Elena valarion and she has now grown
up
um and I hope to see more from her
thanks for the Super Chat from enigmatic
engineer who says sir pounce wouldn't
stand for those rats also this show
doesn't really make the targaryens look
good
I mean honestly like the entire book
Fire and Blood uh does not make uh the
targaryens look good I mean the reason
why the book is called Fire and Blood is
because it's full of all of the blood
that the targaryens shed and the fire
that they burn with I mean the
targaryens are all about like power
violence ambition and Game of Thrones is
so much about the horrors that result
from fire and ambition you know and that
is very much true of this story as well
so uh yeah like
you're not going to come out of this
story going like wow I love targaryens
I'm I'm All Pro monarchy like yeah no
that's that's not that's not how you're
likely to feel about this but like you
know I think that what's great about
this show compared to the book
especially is that we're really seeing
the feelings and the motivations that
underpin uh the the terrible decisions
that are being made
um Milo minda Milo mindibinder in the
Super Chat says was the house mode
character last episode the same person
as Sir Royce in this episode uh no no I
I don't think it was
um this fella is the uh Royce guy he had
that big bushy beard
um and he is not the same person as the
Royce fella
um in this episode who we
uh can I pull up a picture of him I
reckon I can this is the Royce guy so
yeah they do have
um big bushy beards but they are
different fellas but uh look I like that
you're keeping an eye out Milo I like
that you're keeping an eye out for the
inevitable ascendancy of house mud I
don't know about you guys I don't know
about blacks or greens I am team mud all
the way it makes no sense that this guy
claims to be from the long extinct House
of house of mud but uh you know I'm I'm
all for him uh screw the house of the
Dragon give me the house of the mud
thanks for the Super Chat from Mark who
says rhaenyra nigging Daemon into
murdering everyone and flying off with
her was definitely something they are
more alike than she realizes yes I think
there are some deep similarities between
rhaenyra and Daemon for sure
um
thanks for the Super Chat from Brennan
who wanted Joffrey to pull a Monty
Python thanks for the Super Chat from
George who says do you think that Otto's
talk with Alison about the well-being of
the realm was genuine I believed it
yeah I mean like I said I I think that
what Otto said is mostly true like yeah
like there is almost inevitably going to
be conflict when viserys dies and
there's going to potentially be some
people supporting rhaenyra for the
throne some people supporting aegon for
the throne Daemon has his own Ambitions
uh maybe this mud guy is is gonna be the
real claimant to the throne and so I
think otters is just saying be realistic
be pragmatic we gotta make the right
choices to protect you and your children
but again like the only reason why
Alison is in this vulnerable position is
because Otto pushed Alison to hook up
with with viserys in the first place and
because viserys was trying to manipulate
and make aegon the air so like I think
Otto is right that like they've got to
be real about this dangerous situation
but I think the Otto in so many ways
engineered this dangerous situation
um thanks for the Super Chat from meneth
who says honestly this episode just
shows that love doesn't have a place in
ruling with Kristen Cole representing
love yeah I mean Game of Thrones is
always so much about the dangers of
mixing uh political responsibilities
with emotional desires like you know
that's true of Jon Snow and yegrish
um and you know Amon tells Jon Snow you
must kill the boy and let the man be
born and so like you know sometimes like
being a good ruler and being a good man
means like sacrificing your personal
emotional desires for the good of the
realm
um and John does that when he you know
fights against the wildlings and and
Jager gets killed
um so you know maybe Rainier if she
wants to be a good ruler she's just
gotta like
accept that she can't be like you know
getting some side dick from a king's God
she needs to be focused on her
responsibilities because if she doesn't
the white walkers are gonna destroy the
world if the if if they don't marry the
right people if they don't love the
right people if they don't protect this
bloodline and their political stability
then maybe the white walkers will win in
the end you know so there are
apocalyptic consequences to all of this
adultery which raises the stakes
uh Sparty is a fan of Harwin strong
saving Rainier Eugenio says isn't it
clear that the the disease viserys has
is diabetes he's got unhealable wounds
and he's love for wine his escapism is
killing him yeah well he does eat too
much in the book but I am not going to
attempt to diagnose him uh Antoine says
why did Lenor bring his [ __ ] buddy to
his wedding yeah I mean it's it seems to
be kind of an Open Secret like Leno and
um Joffrey's relationship I mean it's a
little bit like uh Loris and Renly and
then Loris and his other lovers
um it's it's not top secret because I
think that when you're powerful enough
you can get away with stuff I mean Lenor
rides a dragon you know so like what are
you gonna do like insult Leno for for
adultery and and you know be homophobic
he's got a dragon
I I think you can get away with a lot
when you've got a dragon I mean George
Martin has said as much like when the
targaryens have dragons they can pretty
much marry who they want it's a lot
easier to get away with polygamy and
incest when you have a dragon
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Jared
what did Daemon do during the brawl yeah
that's not very clear
um
thanks to the super chat for a minute
and Gnostic who says that reminds me of
ovid's metamorphosis the Gathering of
the trees or the birth of Adonis when
Mira becomes a tree and weeps sap thanks
for the Super Chat from Hannis and Nelly
who says when Hobart arrived they
announced him as the voice of old town
perhaps a slight confirmation that the
hightowers do have strong influence with
maesters I mean the home of the Masters
is called The Citadel
um so they didn't mention the Citadel
I'm calling him the voice of Old Town is
just acknowledging him that they ruled
the city of Old Town thanks for the
Super Chat from Clancy who says Kristen
is okay thanks for the Super Chat from
gizka who says what's the deal with
Alaris strong does he have a goal or
does he live for the drama I think he
has political Ambitions because he he
sets himself up as like an ally to
Alison saying oh perhaps you're in need
of an ally and he like turns her against
Rainier so I think Larissa's uh goals
are mysterious but I think he's
ambitious I mean I think one open
question is like what what is the deal
between like Laris and his father Lionel
strong
Lionel strong is the Lord of harrenhal
um does Lionel know about Larissa's
manipulations here like did Lionel say
like hey Laris you should totally go and
tell Alison about the moon T and create
division or as larys just doing his own
thing because it would be really
interesting if like Lionel strong was
like pretending to be like super
supportive of viserys and super unbiased
and just doing the right thing uh when
secretly he's using his son Laris to
actually create Division and [ __ ] around
I think that would be a really
interesting Dynamic
um does Laris tell his brother Harwin
strong brake bones about his
manipulations you know like is Laris
working alone or in concert with
everyone else I think that's a
interesting open question
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Milo
who says
uh yeah well that's a bit spoilery
thanks for the Super Chat from Courtney
who says the last name conversation was
interesting yeah yeah I mean we we
discussed that uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Rebecca who says I love the
wings on the show
but Matt Smith's was horrible Oh you
mean the wigs yeah there's a lot of uh
the the wigs in-house of the dragon have
gotten mixed reviews not Everyone likes
the wigs
um I I don't care too much personally
um I haven't noticed the wigs looking
horrible sometimes like the hairline
above the brow looks a bit wrong
apparently there's been a shortage of
hair for wigs uh it's an issue in rings
of power as well yeah I don't know much
about it
um thanks for the Super Chat from Lady
Eternal who says that viserys only rode
balerion once and never claimed another
Dragon because of his gnarly motion
sickness
yeah that's that's a good theory
um because viserys did once ride
balerion the black dread
which was the biggest and baddest dragon
in the world
um but then balerion died of old age and
uh viserys never rode another Dragon
um you might you might suspect that
maybe the maesters secretly killed
balerion that's what really happened
valerion didn't die the maesters got him
maybe the maesters leeched valerion one
too many times
um but yeah but bellerion died and then
viserys never rode again
um and now he seems sort of afraid of
dragons so yeah maybe viserys is
aversion for Dragons is because he gets
some real nasty seasickness
um I I really like it did look kind of
crazy like when uh
melis and sea smoke were flying around
they were flying really fast like like
melee's like swooped the [ __ ] down from
the sky like look at this they're going
like mac 10. like holy crap your insides
would turn into [ __ ] jelly you would
be liquefied operating it on those kinds
of g-forces I think realistically no
matter how good your saddle is
um
so yeah maybe viseros just got really
Dragon sick and that's why he doesn't
ride but I mean the other angle is that
um no one has ever ridden multiple
dragons people only ever ride one dragon
's gonna have multiple Riders
um one after the other but there's only
ever been one Dragon bonded to one
person so far so you know viserys I
don't think had the option of um taking
another dragon
thanks for the Super Chat from OSH who
said I didn't like Krispy Kreme going
crazy at the party yeah it got a bit
crazy and and I and I did prefer in the
books when Kristen kills Joffrey at a
tournament melee because that is more
sort of forgivable it's more it sort of
makes sense so yeah I agree I would have
preferred if it was at a tournament and
I enjoy Krispy Kreme being the new name
for Kristen Cole I I like that nickname
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Marissa who says shocked that Alison
wore green
at a wedding instead of at a tournament
yeah I mean
they decided to combine the tournament
with the wedding they decided to
compress it they have to simplify things
for this show but yeah I agree like it
is crazy that he killed him at the
wedding
uh thanks for Super Chat from Kauai who
says impressed with the writing of
Allison's turn thanks for the Super Chat
from Musa who says Otto was a piece of
work
yeah yeah yeah I agree Moosa that Otto
like created the problem of this Allison
versus rhaenyra conflict and then he
sort of like blames Alison for not
handling the conflict that he put her in
yeah I agree with that uh thanks for the
Super Chat from moral who says it's
interesting to see the designs and power
of house Hightower compared to the lack
of screen time of their overlords house
Tyrell it shows the Strategic importance
of Old Town
yeah because um
because the high towers are this super
important family but they are not the
most they are not officially the most
powerful house in the reach officially
the tyrells as in like Marjorie Tyrell
and olena Tyrell and Mace Tyrell and
Laura style they are the overlords of
the reach and the hightowers are sworn
to obey the tyrells and yet it seems
like the hightowers are probably more
powerful than the tyrells really and
that comes from their history because
originally the gardeners house Gardener
Ruled The Rage but then aegon the
Conqueror killed the gardeners when he
conquered Westeros and so after aegon
killed the gardeners he was like uh all
right who should I put in charge of the
reach and the tyrells were like oh me me
we should be in charge of the rage and
aegon's like okay fine you're in charge
of the rich I don't care let's go
um and that that has caused a bit a bit
uh conflict because like some people
like the Florence say that oh we should
rule the reach and High Towers think oh
we should Rule The Rage
um and so there's always a bit of
jostling and a bit of conflict in The
Reach when tension in the reach when
other houses think they should be in
charge it's not like the Starks who have
been in charge of the north for
thousands of years the tyrells have only
been in charge for
115 years at this time so
yeah there's definitely some tension
there
thanks for the Super Chat from Nick who
says the hardest part to believe is that
viserys will be alive in 10 years uh
thanks for the donation from dude bro
man dude who says Alison how is Alison
going to get Kristen out in out of
trouble
yeah look I think that in the same way
that Daemon keeps getting away with [ __ ]
I think Kristen may also get away with
[ __ ] uh thanks for the Super Chat from
hen who says do you think Kristen
thought that rhaenyra told Lane Orange
and Joffrey about their relationship
hurting Kristen's Pride yeah I mean
Kristen does Kristen made it clear with
rhaenyra that he does not want to be
seen as Rainier as [ __ ] that's like an
insult to his honor
um so yeah I I guess that
um maybe Kristen thought that Rainier
must have told people that Kristen was
her side piece and maybe Kristen felt
disrespected and that's part of why he
attacked Joffrey yeah that might be part
of it
thanks for the Super Chat from Mike who
says speaking of the word fracus do you
think Frank Herbert masturbate by not
calling June the fracas on arakis
I I think he truly did I think he truly
did and uh Hey hype for uh June part two
coming out next year it's going to be
fun making a video about that
uh all right we're gonna end this live
stream shortly we've been talking for
two and a half hours uh we're gonna do a
real quick uh lightning round to answer
as many of your super chats as possible
and then we're going to have a quick
look at the preview for next week's
episode and then we'll wrap up the live
stream so please do press the like
button and subscribe you can subscribe
to this uh on the alt shift X podcast if
you want to listen to these live streams
as a podcast you can also subscribe to
the alt shift X audio feed so that you
can get alt shift x videos in audio form
in its own podcast feed all of the links
are below uh you can buy an ALT shift X
t-shirt if you'd like or a fancy pin I
think you'd look fetching in that alt
shift X pin at standard.tv alt shift X
link below and we will of course make
the explained video uh it'll come out
around Friday or Saturday uh to follow
up this live stream
and uh yeah let's
quickly answer some super chats so
Abyssal says every time I see the intro
it reminds me of ketchup uh maybe you
are just hungry Abyssal fires you may
have noticed that the intro sequence has
indeed evolved a little bit as the
episodes go by
um there are now some Bloodlines coming
off Rainier which indicates that you
know her marriage to Lenor and
potentially potentially the fruit of
that Union uh and uh Alison over here
has multiple blood streams coming off
her to indicate her multiple children
and her marriage diviserus I guess that
line is her marriage Divas Eris and
these are her children aegon and her
daughter so yeah the opening sequence
continues to evolve
uh thanks for the Super Chat from script
who says was rhaenyra supposed to be
yeah that'll happen later thanks for the
Super Chat from Asher who says Hey alt
do you know who in deep geek is and
would you collab with him yeah in deep
geek is a really cool YouTube channel
and a lovely guy who does uh Song of Ice
and Fire and Lord of the Rings videos
and you should totally check him out
there are there are many many many cool
good uh Game of Thrones channels and
podcasts and stuff you all should check
out radio Westeros and history of
Westeros and Tony Teflon and gray area
and LML and Preston and glidus and
um the disputed lands and good Queen
alley on Tumblr and the not a cast
podcast with Paul Quentin and Manu and
uh Joanna Robinson on the ringer and
many many more who I can't think of
right now there's there's lots of good
channels to check out uh so please do go
check them out on all those podcasts and
stuff uh Dopey Dragon says that maybe
Kristen is a legitimized vol bastard a
vole or are you trying to say Veil I'm
not sure what you're trying to say Derpy
Dragon uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Equinox who says the rats in the
background indicate that the red keep
really needs a rat catcher interesting
observation Equinox uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Lady and King's grave
King's grave says as a as a disabled man
I love the Trope of disabled schemers
and it seems like George R Martin is
also a fan of it yeah George R Martin
has a lot of people who were like
physically not uh what's the terminology
George Martin has lots of people who are
not like physically able and who have
other great talents and you know Tyrion
Lannister is obviously a big example of
that
um he's a dwarf but he's super smart and
has all of these other strengths and
qualities and there's like Willis Tyrell
and he also has a lot of like very fat
people who like are not very capable
because they're very fat but they're
also very like smart and capable and so
like Wyman Mandalay is an example of
that in the books he's like not very
impressive physically but he has a lot
of other talents and like Varys and like
all sorts of people who have physical
shortcomings but uh have other skills
thanks for and you know Lara strong the
club foot is part of that thanks for the
Super Chat from Breyer who says maybe
Daemon acts out because he can never get
it off look I think I think raw sexual
frustration might be half of daemon's
motivations he's got like a chronic case
of blue balls and uh just just cannot
cannot chill there are a lot of
characters in this show who cannot chill
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Archibald who says that Kristen Cole's
indignants about the idea of being
Rainier as [ __ ] when he literally took
an oath of Chastity to become a
kingsguard he should have just played
along yeah he should have just played
along but I mean maybe Kristen felt like
he had to have sex with rhaenyra because
he was she was her princess she was her
princess he would he was she was his
princess
um yeah but yeah Kristen Kristen has a
lot of feelings and he doesn't handle
them very well
thanks for the Super Chat from Bram who
says that have we discussed the murals
of lemon trees around the godswood lemon
trees were there murals of lemon trees
oh yeah there's a mural of a lemon tree
you're right
interesting there is a whole uh lemon
controversy in the Game of Thrones books
because Daenerys Targaryen remembers
growing up in a house that has a lemon
tree which is weird because some people
say there were no trees in braavos or
specifically that citrus trees do not
grow in the cold climate of braavos and
yet Daenerys thinks that this house is
in braavos so some people are like there
must be a conspiracy she must have
actually been at a house in Dawn as part
of the Martell plot line so lemons are
certainly an interesting thing to appear
in on this mural good eye
good eye uh Brown thanks for the Super
Chat from Reuben and from Patrick
uh and from Chris and from helvec
uh yeah we talked about most of the
stuff thanks wrench Dodger
and Princess lioness
and Sean who says why did the hand send
his man to start assaulting what looked
like random people no no so Lionel
strong sent his son Harwin to get
princess Rainier out of the violence
that's what that's what's happened uh it
wasn't it wasn't Lionel sending Harwin
to do more violence he was trying to
just protect the princess which is a
smart thing to do thanks for the Super
Chat from Adam who says when viserys was
being treated yeah yeah yeah yeah it
does seem conspiratorial that Melos
refused to give viserys a medical
treatment suggested by maester Orwell uh
thanks for the Super Chat from
wealthwolf and from Darnell and Jordan
and Kota
and Inquisitor and Jess
who says do you think Hobart hopes to
rise his family above the tyrells in the
long run yeah absolutely there's
definitely some rivalry and some
Ambitions in the reach which might be
relevant in the main Game of Thrones
books
uh groovy says viserys going to call us
is a bit much yeah so it's interesting
that you know King viserys came to
Corliss uh to propose marriage and you
know viserys was kind of offended or
Lionel was kind of offended when the
king arrived on driftmark at high tide
and they're like where is Carlos why is
he not greeting the king I mean remember
like in Game of Thrones season 1 episode
1 when like Robert rocks up and it's
it's a big deal when the king visits
your house like you're meant to make a
big deal of it you're meant to welcome
him with a big entourage and make a big
deal of it whereas here no one welcomed
viserys and I think partly that is
Corliss corliss's Pride he wants viserys
to come to him and so you know Corliss
was sitting on his Driftwood throne and
Carlos was standing up on the Deus and
he was looking powerful forcing the king
to come to him so I think that was
absolutely a power move by Corliss
um to sort of Lord over King heiress
because he feels insulted about Lena and
about rainism so you know his pride is a
huge deal here and it's really
interesting that in corliss's
conversation with rhaenys
um Corliss was the one saying like hey
like it's messed up that you're not the
queen like you should have been picked
at the council at Haron Hall and
rhaenius was like like nah like I'm over
it like I'm okay with not being Queen
whereas call this is like no you should
have been the queen like we need to be
in charge so Corliss is the one who's
really driving the valerion ambition
whereas rhaenys is a bit more chill uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Randall
who says a lot of people are
misunderstanding why Cole snapped he
wasn't angry he just thought he was
going to be tortured and gilded well
yeah but I mean killing Joffrey oh okay
so are you saying that he killed Joffrey
lawnmuth in order to silence Joffrey
lawnmuth in order to prevent joffre
lawnmith blabbing about rain about uh
Kristen breaking his vows and Kristen
was trying to save himself and he was
trying to keep his secret by killing
Joffrey to keep the secret so that he
didn't get killed I think that's an uh I
think that's a fair interpretation but I
don't think that's what's going on
because Kristen had just told Alison he
just confessed to Allison and said
please execute me and then he went to go
and commit suicide by the godswood so I
think Kristen I don't think he's trying
to keep the secret so much as he really
is just overwhelmed with emotion and
self-destructive like he wants to die at
this point
thanks for the Super Chat from Hannah no
I don't think we will see house Dane in
this series but maybe who knows uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Joseph uh
who says are you a fan of Middle Earth
um yeah but I'm not planning on making
Lord of the Rings videos uh thanks for
the Super Chat from Gilly and pizza
uh who says how long will the show go it
might be three or four seasons according
to the show Runners uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Princess lioness
um
thanks for the Super Chat from ship and
Winterfell and Daniel
asks why wasn't Chris McColl wearing a
helmet at the feast I mean so we can see
his face like I I like how you know they
show these characters wearing helmets in
battle a lot of the time like Daemon and
Corliss wear helmets and I like the sort
of realism of that but you know they
want to be able to see
um we want to be able to see the
character's faces thanks for the Super
Chat from
Savona
who says that Kristen had a interesting
background with girls and yet doesn't
want to be one and done with rhaenyra
yeah it does seem like a little bit
hypocritical that Kristen said that he
had an adventurous youth like he was
saying that he slept around when he was
young but he chose not to marry anyone
but now Kristen is getting angry at
rhaenyra that she's sleeping around and
not marrying him so yeah I think there's
definitely some hypocrisy there thanks
for the Super Chat from Gaston
who said when Daemon stepped on Ria's
arm wasn't he checking if she still had
sensation on her arm to check how severe
the paralysis was maybe yeah maybe he
was trying to like assess her situation
but like I I don't see it as an act of
compassion when he kills her with a rock
I think this is pretty [ __ ] up murder
uh thanks with super chat from mesis who
says the book highlighted the moral
ambiguity whereas episodes one to three
were clearly team Target yeah look I
think people have different opinions
about who the good guys are here like I
think I don't know personally I got a
bit of like a villain vibe from Alison
walking in like like she got I got like
Cersei vibes from just her like cold
resentful like like vindictive power
vibe from her
um but you know I I think that we have
seen multiple layers and sides to all of
these characters and I think we will
continue to do so
um thanks for the Super Chat from
what the Tambor
and from Mike
and from Jazz we've already answered
most of these questions I don't want to
repeat myself too much
um
Jazz Falcon suggests that lane or might
blame Rainier for the death of Joffrey
yeah that's an interesting idea or maybe
Lenoir will find comfort with Rainier
like he's grieving his boyfriend at his
wedding terrain here or maybe Rainier
will you know give him a shoulder to cry
on but you're really interesting to see
what kind of relationship they have I
mean they seem pretty understanding of
each other right
um Austin says I've noticed in Game of
Thrones and this show that none of the
targaryens have ever had good control of
their emotions I mean the targaryens are
fiery and some of them have a tendency
towards Madness and erratic behavior and
ambition and pride and love and lust and
also the fact that they have dragons you
know they're powerful they're kings and
queens
um so yeah I think that's part of why
they are super they are pretty erratic
and they do do some dramatic things
and that's what yeah all the drama is
all about
thanks for the Super Chat from hoof who
says why wasn't Otto at the wedding he
was the father of the queen yeah that's
a good point I mean maybe viserys told
Otto you're not welcome at this wedding
you know because yeah it is weird that
the Father of the Bride isn't there
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Marcos
who says Arya destroyed the Song of Ice
and Fire prophecy yeah are you killing
the night King in Game of Thrones was uh
I don't think that does fit particularly
with the prophecies about the prince
that was promised on Azor ahai because
she's not a Targaryen and if it's the
Targaryen bloodline that they're
protecting to fulfill the prince of the
prom prop Prince that was promised
prophecy I don't say are you fitting
into that thanks for the Super Chat from
bandzera uh and thanks for the Super
Chat from Uniden
who says I appreciate them showing
actual love between Corliss and rainies
even if they're plotting a bit thanks
for the Super Chat from Eric and
Virginia
who says are Alison's children not
sharing cribs with dragon eggs yeah I
mean Allison's children are targaryens
aegon Targaryen and her daughter
um shouldn't these true born children
have dragon eggs in their cradle I mean
maybe they do we just haven't seen it
maybe we'll find out
thanks for the Super Chat from first
name
and from Cullen who says if the younger
valerion becomes king consort who gets
drift Mark yeah who does inherit drift
Mark I mean could Lane over Larry on
become Lord of driftmark and also be the
king consort at the same time or will a
second child of Lenor and Rainier get
driftmark or will Kristen or will
corliss's brother vemond get driftmark
there's uh several possibilities there
and inheritance struggles are definitely
part of this plot thanks for the Super
Chat from Tim who says didn't Krispy
Kreme say to Alison that he felt
pressure to sleep with the princess if
it was still his choice uh I don't
remember that line but we can check that
out later uh and kaisha says every
character is gray and Daniel says what
were the dragons we saw flying to meet
the valerions um so I think that the
dragons here are
melis the Red Queen the dragon of rainy
Targaryen and this one is sea smoke the
dragon of Lenor I think those were the
dragons are you saying there were
dragons on the way to the valerians I
don't remember there being dragons here
yeah
um all right we're gonna have a look at
the on the next week preview and then
we're going to wrap up the live stream
so thank you everyone for participating
uh if you don't want to see the next
week preview then you may want to avert
your eyes
because we're going to look at the on
the next episode uh so thank you all for
being here press like And subscribe and
we'll have the explained video out on
Friday or Saturday all right so on the
next episode we see caraxi's flying like
the Glorious awkward wormy weirdo he is
we see the small Council everyone's
older because this is like yeah it's
like 10 years later or something so uh
Lionel strong has got some gray hairs
and viserys is looking extremely unwell
he's got a much more sparse wig now uh
he does not look long for this world and
we have a new actress for Alison and we
have a new actress for Rainier
uh which is gonna be crazy like having
the essential characters replaced I hope
that you know I I hope that the new
actors are as good as the old actors
because uh I think that
um Millie and uh Emily did a really good
job so it'll be really cool to see how
they handle the transition to new actors
years later
um I think that now that we've jumped
forward there's going to be I think
there's gonna be less Big Time jumps in
future uh this kid uh you know mild
spoilers but I think this is uh amond
Targaryen the third child of viserys and
uh viserys and Allison and we save Larry
on ships and we see
the Lannisters roll up
oh we've already seen this stuff
oh yeah that's the wrong bit sorry uh
all right we see this kid training with
a sword and this kid with the long
blonde hair I believe is aegon Targaryen
The Sun the firstborn son of viserys and
Allison and this is the kid who the high
Towers want to inherit the throne uh
that looks like Elena with a child which
is interesting who is Lena hooked up
with uh looks like breakbones is
teaching aegon Targaryen yeah this is
aegon Targaryen I think he's gonna be uh
potentially a claimant to the throne you
will be our King says Alison
we see a dragon egg is that is that is
that Baylor
and we see Lena with Daemon how
interesting and we see this child which
is going to be one of the children of
rhaenyra and her husband Lena of course
we see Harwin break bones some more
looks like Harwin is fighting
against this fella is that Kristen and
Harwin
got a got a boy here he looks very
strong we got Rainier with another baby
so Rainier is going to have a bunch of
kids
and there's going to be a bit of drakara
Singh this is one of the children of
rhaenyra and uh Lenor
with a dragon
so there's gonna be more kids there's
going to be more claimants there's gonna
be more dragons there's going to be more
fights and uh the show is going to
change dramatically
my God this is sort of like a like a
mid-season finale it's going to be a
huge difference between now and the next
five episodes
um so uh my God it's gonna be big okay
we've been streaming for a long time oh
we got a little small dragon with the
dragon Keepers that's cool to see oh and
yeah there's vegar by the way this is uh
this little uh Elena valerion riding the
biggest dragon in the world Vega who
looks appropriately enormous my God does
vega look big Vegas like a dinosaur fago
is a Titan
flying with Daemon too how interesting
yeah I don't I don't want to be spoiling
everything but um we've got a lot to
look forward to we've got a lot of new
characters we've got a lot of changes
but all of these grudges and all these
conflicts that we saw earlier are going
to be super relevant to the whole thing
all right we're going to wrap it up now
thanks guys uh see you next time like
And subscribe check out the podcasts and
uh we'll get going on the explained
video
cheers
[Music]